in a crushing defeat for joe biden the
supreme court has ruled that his mandate
vaccine mandate for private companies is
done it's not going to happen now that's
good news but there still is a bit of a
defeat in that some medical workers can
still be mandated to get the vaccine but
you win some you lose some now here's
where it gets really funny joe biden
he's calling on states to do the right
thing and defy the supreme court and
implement the vaccine mandates anyway
oh you gotta love joe biden and uh it's
just been really really crazy with the
constant authoritarianism we've got
another funny story too and i'll just i
won't bury the lead on this one
newsweek's reporting that joe rogan is
going to be
in dc for this big protest in in about a
week or so where they're all protesting
against the mandates and uh sorry sorry
to spoil it for everybody i have
confirmation joe rogan will not be going
but we'll talk about that story and we
will talk about that protest and and the
reporting here's another crazy one too
the rnc
is going to require supposedly they're
going to require their candidates
potential candidates to sign a pledge
saying they will not participate in
presidential debates with the debate
commission so
it's crazy man what is a crazy day we
also weird yeah we also have the oath
keepers being charged with sedition
seditious conspiracy so um wow man
joining us to talk about all this today
is matt kibbe
how's it going man it's awesome to be
here do you want to introduce yourself
let people know who you are yeah sure i
am the president of a nonprofit called
free the people and our mission is to
use
stories to connect with young people the
values of liberty
with
how we live our daily lives and try to
convince them that that people working
together from the bottom up can do all
sorts of beautiful things
i'm also i run a show
at blaze tv called kibion liberty
and i am a libertarian hopefully
recovering
recovering libertarian you want to just
aim the mic a little bit more up up up
like yeah there you go that's perfect is
that better yeah absolutely
you can't nobody can see the whiskies
unfortunately though i'm like looking at
the camera
unless we do the wide shot if we do the
watch out then we gotta we got luke hey
guys um so
as i become older and that much wiser i
like to give unsolicited life advice and
that's why i made this t-shirt that says
people will forget your words people
will forget your accomplishments but no
one will forget that you voted for joe
biden and i think it's a very important
message that you could also spread by
going to
thebestpoliticalshirts.com it always
starts a lot of interesting conversation
it gets people laughing and if i could
do that i'll be happy thanks for having
me that is a really good shirt it
literally gets everyone everyone's like
like wait wait this is some kind of
cheesy basic b motivational quote no no
we're just making money for [ __ ] joke
for job exactly hi everyone ian
crossland over here happy to be here ian
crossland.net check it out and let's
keep it moving that's right i am also
here i think yes we have the wide shot
here here we have all our whiskies in
front of matt who's going to be doing a
full flight of our whiskey sampler over
from the corner which is going to be
really fun to watch during the show i'm
also here pushing all the buttons in the
corner hi nice to see everybody i've
always dreamed of doing a show called
drunk austrian economics so tonight
might be the night tonight's the night
yes all right before we get started head
over to timcast.com and become a member
in order to help support all of our
fierce and independent journalism as a
member you'll get access to exclusive
members only segments from the tim cast
irl podcast and they're fantastic you
should check out the episodes we just
did recently with mike rowe and marjorie
taylor green
as well as many other people with a
massive library hundreds of these
special episodes including with people
like alex jones and steve bannon so you
definitely want to check that out and
again becoming a member helps fund all
of this and our reporters and we're
hiring more we're working on foundation
so we really appreciate it don't forget
to also smash that like button subscribe
to this channel right now smash that
subscribe button and take the url up top
in the browser and post it wherever you
can far and wide on every platform from
gab to getter to parlor
there are other social media platforms
right anyway those ones work no you can
post it everywhere it really does help
and now let's get into that first big
story we got this breaking news from
timcast.com biden's vaccine mandate for
business is blocked by the supreme court
the court wrote the occupational safety
and health administration was not
permitted to broadly regulate public
health i agree i think they're correct
they wrote requiring the vaccination of
84 million americans selected simply
because they work for employers with
more than 100 employees certainly falls
in the latter category
where they said although congress has
indisputedly given osha the power to
regulate occupational dangers it has not
given the agency the power to regulate
public health more broadly the dissent i
find actually kind of humorous
in the dissent the liberal justices
wrote because it really was split six to
three
when we are wise we know not to displace
the judgments of experts acting within
the sphere of congress marked out and
under presidential control to deal with
emergency conditions today we are not
wise in the face of a still raging
pandemic the court tells the agency
charged with protecting worker safety
that it may not do so in all of the
workplaces needed as disease and death
continue to mount this court tells the
agency that it cannot respond in the
most effective way possible
well there it is and and the daily why
uh the daily wires doing a victory lap
because they were leading the charge on
this they were i think one of the i
think they may have been the original
lawsuit i'm not sure yeah but here we go
that's it joe biden's out no vaccine
amanda right i i think brandon wants to
be a dictator so this is definitely a
step back for him but he's also urging
businesses and states to still implement
this on their own i'm surprised he
wasn't begging the supreme court just to
censor all the arguments here against
his vaccine mandate this is a major blow
against his agenda against the narrative
and thank goodness we don't live in a
country like canada or austria or
australia where people are literally
being robbed of their wealth for not
complying with the whims and medical
advice and then still you know by and
large it's still crazy i bet you
probably agree with this too matt that
we have to be in a place where you know
some mystical figures in robes decided
that we could decide what medicine to
take for ourselves that's that's where
we're at right now that's crazy it was
it was insane and i was freaking out
today because um earlier in the day
everyone expected this to come out and
then they re released some other nothing
burger decision about something that i
don't even remember what it was and i'm
like oh [ __ ] are they going to punch
punt for a week
and and happily they did the right thing
but the absurdity and even even
listening to the more conservative
justices arguing
that it would be okay for a state
or or someone further down the food
chain a different government official to
then impose on you
this this this mandate that you have to
take this vaccine
um i'm i'm of the old school where
individual freedom and and freedom of
conscience is is actually a real thing
and i thought that's what america was
but yeah we dodged a bullet today and
that that was a cool thing i i ascribed
to
a theory that thomas massey introduced
me the day that joe biden
announced this and you remember they
dragged their heels on the rule and
massey's theory was they know it's
unconstitutional they know they're that
they're going to get shot down but in
the meantime they're going to bully as
many businesses as possible into
complying with this and i feel like
biden is proving that theory today you
can't unvex yeah and so what happens is
a ton of businesses when they heard joe
biden issue his press conference which
was not even executive order they just
went okay everybody you got to do it you
heard joe biden and then people
were basically mandated to do it now
they went and got vaccinated they come
back to work and the company goes hey
everybody it's off we actually don't
have the we don't have to do this too
late yeah so i think that was the plan
from the get-go and i feel like um and
maybe we'll get into this in a different
context but i feel like if you were
forced to get vaccinated
maybe secretly you want to kind of force
everyone else to do it too because
you're pissed like you got you got sold
a bill of goods yeah i certainly think
that's true i mean you you take a look
at uh we talked about this last night
uh
vaccine mandates don't work and when i
say they don't work what i mean is in
new york new york city i think they had
the first vaccine mandate they have
skyrocketing covet cases right so
whatever whatever this the point of this
policy is it's certainly not stopping or
abating the spread of covet but yet
still you hear these these democrats and
these these you know city politicians
say it is working why it's forcing
people to get vaccinated it's not
stopping kovid it's just forcing they
call that working yeah so it sounds to
me like they're like i don't care why
you do it just do it i don't care what
the results will be just do it the cult
the culture of compliance right yeah
that sounds like extortion to me just as
just a little bit there but there was
also another ruling specif specifically
with health care workers at facilities
who are receiving medicare and medicaid
funds which was ruled against them which
means that people who are working in
these facilities will have to take the
vacs or lose their jobs at a key time
where already seattle and los angeles
hospitals there have announced that if
they have nurses and doctors who have
tested positive for covid that they need
to come back into work that is
absolutely insane seattle and los
angeles also implemented vaccine
passports for their employees in the
medical staff and and now we're having
covet positive patients
excuse me covet positive nurses and
doctors literally go back to work
dealing with other people inside of
hospitals all in the name of what safety
and security and health yeah sure well
think about medicare and medicaid so
medicare serves seniors over 65
who would be most vulnerable to covid
and most susceptible to ending up in the
hospital medicaid of course serves poor
people so the effect of this most
hospitals take these programs but some
don't but the effect of this
is to specifically understaff hospitals
that are serving seniors and and people
that are struggling to make ends meet
that's what they're doing this is how
government works they're using
government health care now and and
telling people are going to take away
their health care if they don't follow
the government's orders well the logic
was if we're paying for it we being the
federal government
we get to tell you what to do with your
body exactly so welcome to
government-run medicine this is how it
works they own you and they decide what
you do have to do but they also decide
what you don't get to do
like joe biden has has nationalized
monoclonal antibodies
yeah oh one of them now
they're trying to shut that down i'm
hearing yeah so i was actually recently
told by a meta a
medical worker that
they no they were told monoclonal
antibodies no longer work and that
they're not to recommend them and that
to me is insane what yeah well that's
just me personally look i'll tell we we
always tell everybody we're not here to
give medical advice and that's like a
big topic because of so much of what's
going on the pandemic go talk to a
doctor and see what they say about it
because i'm being told that they're
starting to pull monoclonal antibodies
well i had a friend who was sick with
covid19 and you know they were they were
having a very serious case of it some of
the early preliminary data is
highlighting how some of the antibodies
don't work but there is one specific
antibody that does work with omnicron
but for delta a lot of them do work by a
broad basis this is just again some of
the preliminary early findings i'm not a
medical doctor not here giving you any
kind of medical advice but it has been
siphoned off and my friend who was
trying to get antibodies for herself and
her husband because they weren't doing
too well was told because of biden
because of the governor in new york you
can't get them and there was even an
article
in the um the daily mail that said
whites need not apply for critical
covert care for antibody
care because of their skin color as of
course they're also passing laws in many
places like in new york where if you
were born a specific skin color you're
denied access to medicines compared to
other people because of their skin color
remember uh death panels hmm yes i mean
i i yeah what was that that was back in
like 2008 that was like fear-mongered
techniques of obamacare that there's
going to be government-run health care
and the government's going to decide who
lives and dies uh that was that right
that was the story that's not wrong was
that wrong that's exactly how it works
i know this very personally my wife uh
terry got got covered over christmas
and okay i'm i'm gonna get monoclonal
antibodies and it turns out that they
pulled two of three types of monoclonals
off the market the bite administration
did because the assumption was they work
on delta but they don't work on omicron
and so they pulled all of these things
away from the hospital so in in our case
we couldn't get
treatment for my wife she's fine now but
it she would have done better with them
and then it turns out that you know we
thought it was all omicron but it's not
really all omicron there's a lot of
delta out there
and and it's sort of a lesson in how um
single top-down decision-making works in
government they just arbitrarily said
you know what it looks like omicron now
well it wasn't
and catastrophically someone at the
margin probably died because of this
government decision we don't know who
that is
but but someone could have gotten
treatment and and some bureaucrat in the
body administration said you know what
we're not going to let you i think i
think there's no one here as a fan of
centralized command control you know
economic structures or governmental
structures right no you know in the
military so i i mean when it comes to
military it's like yeah when it comes to
military i understand the need for
authoritarian top-down generals that's
that's that's a fair point i agree with
that yeah that's why we have
an executive structure you know because
when we got to move fast in emergencies
it does make sense but we're at this
point now where too much is being
absorbed by this executive authority
it can't be
you know total control of our medical
system in one place
the fda is also intercepting packages
with medicines that some people are
using to help treat this so when you
have the government outright intervening
in such egregious ways and you see the
result of it when more people being hurt
it really really should leave a lot of
people with the questions what are they
doing here other than making the
situation that much worse for everyone
else as you said the fda was
intercepting packages with specific
medications that have been of big topic
of debate uh obviously these are the
medications that joe rogan has talked
about before i don't even want to name
them because of the kind of hot button
i came across a video on twitter where
it's apparently there's been a bunch of
uh thefts of train packages in la i
don't know if you guys saw this on the
scanner they they heard about it they
went down there and it's like just
ripped open packages of amazon packages
boxes covet tests fishing lures epipens
crazy is it piracy is it good is it this
is what crossed my mind as you were
saying that are people being
privateering these stuff back to what we
were talking about i wanted to uh
get back to the point about executive
authority and the need for you know
emergency response
my view of emergency response is there's
an agency that says okay we're going to
go to these local communities that are
affected by a pandemic and ask them what
they need and we can do that very very
quickly because we have the authority to
respond rapidly but not to dictate what
the communities have to do not to go to
local mayors and say you're now mandated
to do this so when you look at here's
what i love about about mask mandates
especially
we we work on the border with frederick
county and i think washington county and
maryland and so you can like walk 10
feet and there's a building with a mask
mandate and then walk 10 feet and
there's one without and it just
literally makes no sense and then the
crazier thing is the further the further
out you get from the center of the
county the less likely you are to even
experience the mass mandate which it
just does not work but then they want to
start punishing businesses and finding
them and it's just like look
being able to rapidly respond to a
crisis by showing up with resources you
can spend money you have people working
under you and you can say here's what
needs to be done makes sense
but if you go to a community you ask
them what they need you don't tell them
what to do you know yeah i mean that
that's the dream but the problem is
there's uh there's a fatal conceit um
when you give these guys that much power
they have their own theory about how to
do it and and and the the most
disturbing example of this we all know
is andrew cuomo overruling nursing home
providers
murdering 15 000 murdering 15 000 people
he probably thought he was doing the
right thing he probably thought he knew
better than them and the problem with uh
governments using local knowledge is is
that arrogance they don't they don't
want to see the fact that they don't
know because that's political danger for
i i disagree um with andrew cuomo not
thinking he's doing the right thing
though like i understand your point i
agree with that but cuomo had the mercy
medical vessel any of the javits center
and he was like i'm not giving trump a
victory kill the old people
he was warned cuomo was warned if you do
this you will kill old people
and he said instead of using the under
the the javits center which is only at a
third capacity or the mercy vessel which
isn't being used at all i'm gonna kill
the old people and he did or the central
park hospital that was there that had
received no one i mean you could even
fascistly say that he was on the phone
with his brother at cnn being like hey
we need more of those debts to boost up
ratings as of course there's cnn
officials literally bragging about how
they were happy how more people were
dying
because it was gangbusters for ratings
which is absolutely absurd so again
that's the thesis it's sensationalistic
to say that but it's not out of the
realm of possibility with how they've
been behaving man we i this this is this
kind of stuff that makes me want to do
sketch comedy because you can't do it on
youtube but you'll be able to do it on
rumble yeah where you just have chris
cuomo call up andrew and he'll be like
chris my show's not doing too well we
need more deaths what can you do for me
well little brother uh i got you i got
you we'll just kill a bunch of old
people
i i you look uh it's it's it's it's
meant to make fun of them for as bad of
people as they are but
andrew cuomo knew what he was doing oh
people come out it was standard protocol
this is why there's such a big kind of
uh you know talk about conspiracy of him
being outed because if he got hit with
that if he got was if he was responsible
for that so would a lot of other
democratic governors in michigan in new
jersey who would have been held
responsible for it and that's why
there's conspiracy thought talk of
andrew being kind of taken out so there
there wasn't any kind of possibility of
him facing any justice for that specific
cause because it would implicate all
these other governors that were
democratic that were following orders
from the federal government that was
telling them to do this let's talk about
joe biden
so in this report from the daily mail
they mentioned that the supreme court
has voted 63 to block biden's vaccine
mandates however a disappointed joe will
tell businesses to adopt the rules
anyway
and says it's up to states to do the
right thing
biden has urged businesses to bring in
vaccine mandates on their own and push
states to do the right thing if the
supreme court voted 63 to block his
sweeping rules on private companies in a
crushing blow to his pandemic response
the high court did however allow a
vaccine medic for employees at
healthcare facilities receiving federal
dollars to go into effect now there's an
important distinction here
joe biden is saying ignore the supreme
court in a certain sense but the supreme
court did not rule that vaccine mandates
are completely illegal the supreme court
ruled that joe biden doesn't have the
authority through osha to mandate
businesses require vaccinations so joe
biden comes out and says then it's up to
you guys to implement these because i
can't force you to do it now you know i
think it's going to happen i think i
think the blue states and i think all
the big companies are going to do it
anyway mm-hmm unfortunately though it
means i guess like the daily wire won't
have to well they're going to try to do
it but there's also a very interesting
article also from the daily mail talking
about how a lot of the cases are
flatlining in a lot of these major
democratic states and if this goes along
with the theory that i've been talking
about and many other medical
professionals have been talking about
for a few weeks now there should be a
sharp decline in the numbers just like
we have seen in south africa i might be
wrong on that assessment and that theory
but if that's the case they're going to
have a hard justification for more
lockdowns more mandates and i think this
is their kind of last push and i think
this is a major setback against their
agenda and i don't see it going further
from here from my perspective it's kind
of a dilemma for businesses because on
the one hand they're dealing with
employees some of whom are karen's right
they they want that vaccine mandate and
they want double masking and they
they're scared to death
but there's other employees that say i'm
not going to do it and you're going to
lose me and those may well be some of
their most important employees but you
have the chief executive officer of the
united states saying
i got an offer for you that you can't
refuse
and if you say no
i'm going to send some of these agencies
to check out your stuff and make sure
that you're in full compliance with osha
full compliance with this there are so
many rules and regulations that every
company in america is surely violating
right now because they couldn't possibly
know what they are
biden still has
the ability to make their lives help and
what i think a lot of the big
corporations wanted was the cover of
being forced to do it
by by the government and now they're
stuck in this place
and they're going to discover that
they're going to lose a lot of their
talent if they push forward i got i got
to tell you you know um i can certainly
sympathize and empathize with a lot of
these businesses because there are
people who
won't admit when they get sick because
they're like no no i'm not sick you know
everything's fine and then they'll come
into work and they'll get people sick
you also have managers who are like i
don't care if you're sick i don't want
my boss yelling at me you better show up
for work and so then you have these you
know executives who are like how do we
stop people from from doing this and
they're like well we can mandate a
vaccine i guess i'm not convinced
vaccine mandates are going to solve the
problem so you know ultimately i can
empathize with the problem uh
of people spreading covet and then your
your company gets shut down i get it we
had to you know take off for a week
because we got sick and i can see why
people are worried about that but i
think we have to realize we're living
with this yeah well what's you've got to
define the problem what's the problem
today overloading the hospitals that was
the problem two and a half years ago
how do we solve that obviously the
vaccine
may reduce symptoms but it doesn't seem
to stop the spread doesn't seem to stop
people from getting it
um i think people are going to the
hospital after they've been vaccinated
so
you're looking to solve the problem that
that solution didn't seem to solve it
well that's that's a good question
what's the problem i don't think there
really is one labor shortages supply
chain problems economics
that's a great point because it's that's
not coveted related anymore yeah and
then why are why is the ap telling them
not to report on single like single case
record increases in certain states what
was that all about because it seems like
they're shifting the narrative from oh
my gosh so many people are getting
decoded or getting covet to being more
like well it's still a problem we still
have to worry about it but we also have
a midterm to win or something i'm not
sure what the strategy is there so what
was the deal with their their decision
to say you can't talk about these
increases these sharp increases you
don't remember they're looking for an
exit strategy and and they've been
scaring the crap out of people for two
years now
and and they're there there is no
problem there's certainly not a problem
that we can do anything about at this
point i mean i think we've created a lot
of collateral damage and you remember
the original covet models said if you're
going to flatten the curve you're going
to push out the pandemic
and that was always part of the model
and here we are two years into it and
this is an extraordinary virus in its
behavior and and i think that all of
these central planners who thought they
knew better are culpable so they they
need an exit strategy and if we can just
tone down the hysteria on the data
maybe we can get out of this before the
midterm i think it's very yeah it's got
to be political absolutely i definitely
agree you we've been talking about it
for a few weeks now and this could be
why jake tapper said you know the
hospital numbers are inflated this is
why the cdc came out and said 75 percent
of debts are because of four or more
comorbilities this is why the new york
governor came out said around 40 percent
of the hospitalizations are literally
people who were there not because of
corona but with corona because of other
incidences and there's more and more of
these announcements something is
definitely going on here and and i think
there's definitely a bigger agenda at
play here i figured out luke's agenda
by saying words like comorbility yeah
the ai on youtube can't track the words
he's saying to censorship you should
have seen what i was saying a specific
kind of medication a year ago
um i will remember it forever you guys
remember last year we were i'm not going
to say it here but there's a specific
way i was specifically mentioning stuff
but you're developing your own sensor
proof language i couldn't i'm going to
play it off like that but that's not the
case but
there's this uh there's this font that
allows people who are dyslexic to read
read it oh cool and it's it's really
interesting it's got like thicker
portions on parts of the letters and i
feel like that's kind of like this luke
will say the word comorbility and the ai
just goes like i'm not familiar with
this i almost had it it's kind of like i
think uh
well who was it was it uh leonardo da
vinci wrote in code because it was
illegal the church would have him
executed if he they knew he was talking
about the stuff he was talking about
heliocentric model i think that was da
vinci galileo maybe wrote
wasn't alice in wonderland and through
the looking glass
you know it's meant to be metaphorical
supposed to be uh representing the
problems of government and everything
like that you gotta hide from the
algorithm you gotta slightly move
through it it's always been thinking yes
wow
well regardless of algorithms big tech
is a big problem in terms of limiting
speech and shutting down descent and
shutting down conversations but uh i i
feel at this point
with what biden is saying i don't know
if the democrats are going to get the
message before the midterms right
how does joe biden come back from the
supreme court struck down his mandate he
then
double triples down saying do it
anyway and then we're supposed to
we're we're gonna expect democrats to
change their minds in a few months and
be like everyone's free now vote for us
because if they keep running on
lockdowns they're gonna lose yeah well
he's got two fundamental problems one is
that the people
that
were forced to be vaccinated the people
that lost their jobs or the people that
are looking at empty grocery shelves
are going to show up and midterms are
low turnout elections so the midterms
are going to be dominated by people that
have suffered under the under the biden
regime and the other problem and this
goes back to what james carville so
famously said it's the economy stupid
it's going to be very hard to fix what
they've done in terms of supply chains
in terms of employment problems in terms
of all these things that people are
feeling
at the very local level
there's there's no way to turn that
around in time so i think they're faced
with what they're doing is like let's
just keep doubling down and hope for a
miracle but
it it seems like political suicide to me
yeah i agree with you if if people came
out of the lockdown and the economy was
where it was three years ago i think
it'd be fine people would be like cool
biden all the way but it did they
inflated the economy so heavily by like
100 percent almost yeah did you did you
see when uh 80 percent tomal harris got
asked if the ticket was going to stay
the same and she goes look we are
focused on you know today and i'm like
it's really weird she couldn't just be
like yeah
you know what i mean i guess she was
like i know what you're trying to do
with the pundits and the talking points
you know because they're saying but we
are focused on what's happening today
and i was just like
just say yes but the reality is the
answer is not yes yeah it's not going to
be budgeting
in a few months they're going to throw
away biden like the worn puppet that he
is they're going to throw him by the
wayside he's going to be gone and
they're going to bring in someone else
they're they're teasing they're they're
literally teasing hillary
um and and other people that they're
trying to bring to the forefront buddha
judge is another one um i think it might
even be even something like uh michelle
obama or oprah who knows what they're
doing but i i do not see any way unless
they make uh you know clones of him um
or some kind of gmo creature and put
them in the front of us i don't see how
they're going there is a conspiracy
theory they cloned by no joke or they
replaced him or something it's silly but
remember when barack obama said to biden
you don't have to do this do you
remember that quote yep see we always we
always assume the context of that quote
is you don't need to be the man who who
tries to stop donald trump when in
reality he was saying like you don't
need
like it was more of a you don't need to
do this like you're not qualified yeah
you are not qualified for this job what
i get and and joe biden listens he hears
it and in his mind he's like this hero
saving the day and biden's like
you you don't need to do that joe let's
uh let's go back to the sun room and get
you your blanket and get you a nap and
joe was like oh true not a shot at a
pressure the the last desperate throws
of george bush 41
was his staff leaking all of this stuff
about how dan quayle was the problem
so if you're blaming your vp for the
failure of your presidency
you're probably already done
i don't think they ever planned on biden
going beyond one term and they can they
can they can play it up like they did
intend for him to be a two-term
president but the reality was we all
know what joe biden is he was the
corporeal form that they asked for just
a warm body that was not donald trump
it's like an old episode of star wars
yeah yeah star star star trek star trek
yeah they got what they wanted and now
we are all much worse off for it
but if you are a wealthy political elite
sitting atop your ivory tower
they're happier that trump isn't in in
in office
even though everyone else is suffering
so long as they're better off because
trump was a bull rampage and through and
they don't care about you i could see if
andrew yang had gotten into presidency
and they were like we're going to print
5 trillion he would have been like nah
and he would have been obstructing all
this money printing so like they needed
someone like biden who's just i just
said you've got the reigns anthony i
absolutely disagree with you
he would give that money to he would
reduce that money yeah i don't know it'd
be like a lot of them actually it it it
does make sense to bolster the economy
by by printing more money because
everyone will then have money to spend
and eat food with and you know we should
do it and i actually like andrew yang
but i definitely think he would be like
print money but that would have been
like 1.2 trillion not six trillion
ian with the way that the government
does they would give everyone money and
then give themselves twice as that he
worked for cnn i have absolutely no
faith and trust in that man i think it's
awesome that 1.2 trillion is considered
fiscally
yeah spend money to make money modern
monetary theory is breaking down because
we don't have industry in the united
states we're putting all this money into
something that's not getting us a return
and the money's disappearing all right
we got you know sometimes i get really
bummed out when the news is like all joe
biden and all hard policy stuff and
scotus i'm like where's that where's
that matrix you know we talked about the
matrix and we talk about some cultural
stuff but it's
i i'm sorry my friends here we go in the
post-millennial
biden begs press and social media to
censor misinformation and disinformation
from platforms quote i make a special
appeal to social media companies and
media outlets he said please deal with
the misinformation and disinformation
that's on your shows it has to stop
and i'm pretty sure he just committed a
constitutional violation yeah because
the government can't incentivize or make
requests of private companies to violate
people's rights that is still a
government violation of someone's rights
so if
i actually actually tweeted this that
the vaccine mandates are a violation of
our right to peaceably assemble
think about it i mean it's just it's
it's it's a it's a it's a um it's a
workaround the government can't use
workarounds to violate people's
constitutional rights so if you have a
city
uh new york and they say
you cannot enter
any private establishment except for the
ones we exempt unless you get a medical
treatment that violates our right to
assemble joe biden right now is
violating our right to speech by begging
big companies to shut down what he views
as misinformation and disinformation so
while as bad as that is i'm actually
really happy about this it shows you how
utterly pathetic
and desperate they are we talked about
how cnn's ratings were down 91
over last year they're getting less than
like a hundred thousand viewers in the
key demo they have no influence anymore
and in ten years when they're when their
viewers age out of politics
they're done their narrative is over so
what does joe biden do he begs he gets
on tv and says please
he's sitting there crawling amid the
desert begging just water please and
we're sitting there with our canteen
going
no well these big tech companies might
oblige him for sure watching watching
them back
they got rid of the like button on
youtube yeah but
because of because of dr
biden administration's youtube channel
being just obliterated by dislikes every
time he went on when a politician begs
you and they have no authority it's
really a good feeling he has a lot of
authority and i die and the intelligence
agencies have long extensive ties to big
tech social media so again it is
interesting to see him beg i mean his
poll numbers have also dropped they
dropped 11 points uh from last month
according to the quincy pack poll so
obviously he is not doing good at all
quinnipiac same thing potato potato you
know what i'm saying you're just trying
to be smug right now no somebody
somebody super chatted is the ai censor
looking for the word with because luke
has never pronounced that word correctly
i'm gonna talk about how
i'm gonna speak english how i wanna
speak english
there's also this other headline that i
read today that said biden dodges
question on covet and smirks at press
conference soon after rambling speech
where he bungled his testing czar's name
and announced plan for one billion tests
and and you know how is that not popular
how are people not supporting him in his
larger efforts he just looks so lost he
does exactly
it looked like someone needed to like uh
pick him up and yeah and take him
somewhere
that's what i was saying about you know
biden or obama when he said you have to
do this he was like come on let's get
you in the chair and you're really in
the sun with your blanket and you can go
to sleep
here's your warm milk yes
the video you're referencing too luke is
incredible i mean it's like him like 45
seconds standing there like breathing
slow looking down almost laughing at the
ridiculousness of it yeah ignoring
questions it was it was awful this press
conference he did where
he said i i can't even i can't even tell
you what he said because it was
jibber-jabber nonsense he was just like
we got it one thing we don't want to
we don't want to uh do um
working to track that wait no we don't
want to work and i'm just like what is
wrong with this guy
it's because you know what i think you
know you know what happens joe biden is
an old man
to to say he's passed his prime
it's an understatement
he's what comes after your prime well
he's after his decay yeah he's after the
decay he's now he he you know look with
all due respect to anyone who's older
there's a certain time in your life
where you sit back you smell the flowers
and you just you've done it you've lived
your life joe biden was there
and they needed that warm body and
someone came to him and said joe can you
read cue cards and he was like
yeah and they were like we think he can
pull this off
and then within only a few months he
lost the ability to even read from the
teleprompter and now here we are the
emperor has no clothes you know what i
love though is that as much as we are
all that kid pointing at the emperor and
saying he's not wearing any clothes
there are still people around no he's
wearing clothes he is he is all there he
is sharp as attack
who are you fooling
you know
quinnipiac has his approval rating at 33
incredible one-third of this country
genuinely thinks that joe biden is
competent wow that's scary that's high
yeah that is really high well those are
the true believers that are not going to
admit that they made a horrible mistake
by by voting for the guy
but it's
it's sort of this this
it's it's like it's like it's like a
religious fervor that people have for
their guy and in this case biden
and they just they'll watch that same
press conference and say i think he did
pretty good
he made it like
and so it's
what do you do to convince that third
nothing well maybe he doesn't need the
third he needs the people the swing
voters that are going to decide whether
or not he matters he's got him yeah
independents have swung for for for uh
the republicans at this point or away
from democrats i was looking at one
study that that tracked the um
party switching from 2016 to 2020
independent uh has become the smallest
faction because they're mostly
polarizing
but the about uh two to one they go to
republicans
so uh maybe it's a little bit too
generous actually it's it's it's it's a
it's a bit more independent voters are
becoming republican but a large amount
of democrats are becoming republican as
well even their best their best of in
the party like tulsi gabbard and andrew
yang i believe andrew yang left the
party too didn't he he did he started he
started the forward part they both left
the democratic room too that's a jump
party now i don't there's no room for
those guys in the party
yeah right they're pushed out so um are
you familiar with kim iverson yeah she's
she's great she tweeted that she was
gonna be she sent her left she's fairly
progressive we've had her on the show
and she's very much left of me and i'm
fairly moderate
she tweeted she was voting straight
republican and when i saw that tweet it
was on the 8th i was surprised because i
was like i
haven't even committed anything like
that and i
hate the democratic party but she said
anything to stop the mandates and it's
not going to be democrats now the funny
thing is i see vosh the the you know the
socialist commentator say oh what a what
a completely shocking turn of events and
i'm just like are you not upset that
you're you're bleeding out that your
center like you you're you're right
flank you are losing support every day
and your attitude is haha
i really think that covet
authoritarianism and lockdowns and
vaccine mandates these are the only
issue
that matters and and all the the blue
checks and the media have ignored for so
long this this this boiling up
bottom-up culture
of people that are just pissed off and
and they feel violated maybe they lost
their jobs or maybe maybe they just had
personal medical reasons for not not
being forced to mandate this vaccine
i think that's who's going to show up
and i think it's the beginning of a a
new political realignment that i've i've
hoped to see it for a very long time
authoritarians you've said this a
thousand times authoritarians versus
people that just want to be free to live
their lives yeah and that's why i think
we do see some republicans join the
democratic party those are the
authoritarians yeah the the the lincoln
project types
they just want to be rich they want to
be in control they think you're stupid
my michael bloomberg is he really a
democrat i mean he's bounced back and
forth and he's the guy who thinks you
shouldn't be allowed to buy soda because
you're too fat and i'll tell you this
sure i think people who are overweight
should probably lose weight but i'm not
going to tell you you can't have a soda
you know how am i going to track your i
can't track your whole life it's insane
to me and so what ends up happening is i
might you know on policy issues be a
little bit more collectivist than your
average conservative but on issues of of
freedom and liberty i'm like well if we
can't vote for it we can't agree i'm not
going to force anyone to do it and the
democratic party in the left the
establishment left has overwhelmingly
become shut up and do as you're told and
adhere to the cult and the collective so
they're losing people they're going to
gain those wealthy neocon types who want
to go to war and want to control people
but now we're starting to see much more
libertarian values and little
libertarian um
civil libertarianism joining the right
and that's i think it's a fantastic
opportunity a lot of people on the left
a lot of democrats don't get that i'll
be talking to people who are like you
know democrat leaning and they'll say
something about the republican party
from 20 years ago they'll be like yeah
well the republicans are the ones who
did this with afghanistan and iraq and i
was like yeah i agree that was really
really bad i would never vote for those
guys
but rand paul i don't know he's against
all that stuff
i i liked bernie sanders but he sold out
to the machine
so now that we're seeing more people
like thomas massey and you know rand
paul i'm i'm getting happier with the
republican party donald trump trying to
get our troops out of the middle east
i'll take it i'll i'll take it man
you saw bill crystal uh leave the
republican he was basically one of the
architects of the iraq you know all the
war in the middle east and then he left
and joined the democratic and the link
yeah and the lincoln project i don't
know much about them
they're there it was really funny
they're like the republican party is the
party of lincoln and donald trump has
besmirched our name so we're gonna take
the party back and then you know after
2020 they're like and now that we're
still trying to make money we're gonna
go after republicans anyway and
everyone's like aren't you the party of
lincoln and they're like eh
when it was when the children they went
after children too that's another story
when the when the dust settled it turned
out that they were all just neocons that
had become republicans in the first
place they were democrats before but
they'd become republicans because they
really liked war
and when when trump sided with rand paul
and and the the fairly small liberty
wing of the republican party
that was a shot across the bow because
they lost control at the top
and i think i think a lot of this um
never trump hysteria can really be
described
by attempts to to scale back some of the
never-ending wars yeah definitely i
don't think trump was perfect in that
regard but you know i didn't vote for
him in 2016 when i was looking in 2020
and i saw the timeline for withdrawal
for afghanistan i saw trump complaining
about syria i saw trump openly bragging
about selling weapons to these countries
i was like we're getting a little bit of
honesty in that regard and he is trying
to get out it's the best i've seen in my
life so i'm for it he didn't start any
new wars but that's one of the reasons
they really really hate yeah he was he
was very far from perfect and he never
actually succeeded in getting us out of
afghanistan and i think that was
a strategic political mistake also a
policy mistake on his part
but that's the future the future
is
let's focus on personal responsibility
and individual liberty
and maybe let's do less of this war
stuff um every war that the government
declares and it's not just
the wars uh the war on terrorism the war
on covid has been the same damn thing in
terms of enriching um the corporate
interests that collude with governments
to do all this stuff against the rest of
us and and you know the the
military-industrial complex there's a
covet industrial complex and man six
trillion dollars buys a lot of interest
yeah just like the war on drugs the war
on covid the war on terrorism just
breeds more drugs coveted terrorism as
of course there's profit incentives
built within the government and the
larger institutions that corrupt them
that of course profit highly off of
those problems being made worse as
they're being sold to you as they're
going to be the solutions to them when
they're not but i'm fairly optimistic i
think that no matter who wins in the
culture war this is the end of the
american empire it's the the end of this
global american you know mission
military bases overseas will probably
start shrinking and the reason i think
that is
the right side whatever that really
means i don't know because it's not it's
not about conservative values
necessarily but it is more about
anti-war it's about freedom it's about
personal responsibility i think if that
succeeds like trump trump supporters
civil libertarianism you've got no
willpower towards foreign war zero none
of these people want it if the
establishment ends up winning if the
left i mean you've still got the
progressive flank coming in and they're
just chaotic and destructive
so if the personal responsibility
individualist faction does succeed
america is going to come back to just
working for america and then the end
result the left should be cheering about
well
real quick the progressive activists
should be celebrating that
trump supporters hate war
instead they're combating against them
which says to me they're just chaotic
and destructive so if if the democrats
are the establishment unit party is not
long for this political world i was
going to say that i think isolationism
we had that before world war one i think
and uh part of why world war one broke
out is because u.s
looking back maybe wasn't involved not
really is it not the reason why but
uh you know the military-industrial
complex basically was in 1946 i think
the liberal economic order got created
basically to get put american military
bases all over the world british
american french military bases and then
defend make sure that another world war
three never breaks out another world war
never breaks out um
and i also agree that american
imperialism is on a decline i don't know
if that means that there's not going to
be any military bases america is going
to isolate and then a world war is going
to break out i mean that's that cannot
happen that is to all these military
authoritarians they do not want that to
happen you well you've got the um the
joe biden special interests that are
basically selling us out to china
so
if they gain power then the u.s just
crumbles i guess they want to sell off
all of our assets and resources to china
and extract the value from this country
and then we're left holding an empty bag
and then you have the trump side which
says we want to defend our borders bring
industry and jobs back to the united
states and then there's just no there's
not going to be any power will po or or
uh force of will towards international
conflict from the united states at the
very least do they consider iraq part of
our borders
what the right no like joe biden i know
it's a question you can't answer and you
don't know but do you know
probably does here's here's what we got
going on the reason one of the reasons
they really hate donald trump is because
their long-standing plan with europe
natural gas oil pipelines and all that
was was disrupted to such an absurd
degree boy were they spinning
they wanted to build the pipeline i've
talked about this but they wanted to
build the pipeline the cutter turkey
pipeline through syria through turkey
into europe to offset the gazprom you
know gas monopoly as soon as trump got
in they knew that plan was done
everything they had been working on was
going to be shut down because donald
trump didn't want to be involved in
these foreign wars he didn't want to be
involved in syria he didn't want to be
involved in afghanistan and that meant
we would the united states would not be
able to win this international conflict
in the region
so they did everything in their power to
shut them down further donald trump
here's what i really think i think
donald trump genuinely was like i don't
know why we have any of this stuff and
the bureaucratic state is probably like
listen we have a plan you need to do
this and he's like i don't care he's
like america america i don't know why
you're doing this and he ignores them
and he won't listen
and then
stumbling bumbling donald trump and i
know he's not really but i mean in this
one capacity
he stumbles upon a video of joe biden
demanding a quid pro quo with ukraine
and trump gets on the phone he's like
what's that all about and the
bureaucratic state goes no
like that's our plan we have a company
we've a proxy company we've set up in
ukraine the vice president son is on the
board we got a former cia director we
are we are working ukraine to get gas
into europe and trump just blurts it out
they and then that's why they did
everything in their power to stop trump
it wasn't about fascism or racism it was
that trump was just he wasn't supposed
to win he was not a part of their stupid
plans and he was dismantling them and
for four years he really set them back
now joe biden is left with the the
neo-liberal establishment neocon
uniparty plan just in shambles and i
don't think they can recover from it to
be honest
i would push back a little bit uh so he
had some populistic policies that do
deserve to be commended and and
respected no matter what side of the
political aisle you're on but he did
continue the the war in yemen fighting
alongside al qaeda fighting alongside
the saudi coalition creating one of the
worst humanitarian crisis in the world
he did he did give ukraine lethal
weapons he did send a crapton of drone
strikes to the point and extent where he
stopped even listing them and even being
transparent about them and then he also
bombed syria because his daughter came
to him and said she saw a scary video
online according to donald trump's own
son so with that happening he brought us
very close to russia that fits
i don't think we disagree
the yemen afghanistan stuff is what
trump knows he knows 911 he knows that
so when they come to him and say this
goes oh okay i'll do that i'm not saying
what he was doing was good i'm saying he
was dismantling their plan because he
didn't understand or care about their
you know circuitous plan towards gas you
know interdependency and when it came to
bonding syria yeah you're right it was
his daughter
the the bureaucratic state
trump hated the head of the fbi hated
the cia he didn't like any of these
people they had smeared and lied about
him so he was ignoring them outright but
when it came to his his daughter and his
son-in-law he was like sure i'll do what
you guys say and so they couldn't
control him and i'm not saying that
means trump was doing good things it
just means their real reason for
opposing him is that
you know i'll put it this way
it is said and and tell me if you guys
agree that the deep state is called the
bureaucrat the administrative state
they have plans and those plans extend
beyond the terms of the sitting
president so when the new president
comes in they say here's the operation
we're currently working on and typically
the president goes okay you got it obama
would do it right
bush would do it and then trump gets in
and he goes no i'm not going to do it
you can't tell me what to do i've got
plans and then all of a sudden they're
angry and freaking out because trump
isn't playing ball 100 there you go yeah
there was an aspect where he was a bull
in a china shop and he said well we're
just going to take the oil in syria i'm
going to leave the military there and
there was also military individuals that
were lying to him about the exact
numbers of u.s troops inside of syria
which is also mind-boggling boggling
when you think about it in that kind of
perspective but i i think he should
always be judged on his actions uh in
each direction uh but i agree but i
think a lot of people weren't expecting
him to be in there and i think he
capitulated some he fought some but uh i
think that's up for a lot of people's
own personal interpretation way too much
yeah way too much capitulation and i'm
sure you guys have covered this in a
different conversation but uh
my my theory without any evidence is
that he took a dive on snowden because
they made him hmm
how do you explain that and assange too
yeah assange and ross albrecht yep that
he couldn't do it i i kind of feel like
trump thought he was gonna he was gonna
get a second term
and so he was you know i'll hold back a
little bit because i want another term
and then when it started looking bad for
him he said i can't go crazy because i'm
going to try again and he thinks he's
going to get it in 2024. and then
i'll tell you this man
if donald trump
takes the white house in 2024 he takes
the election and then in 2025 you know
come january 20th or whatever there is
another trump administration
he will emerge from that white house
with glowing red eyes and ener energy
emitting from his body as he raises his
finger and he says arrest them all and
he just goes after every single one of
these people who who wronged him or
sliding him who slighted him who smeared
who lied because he's on he's going to
be unrestrained he's just going to be
i'm done playing this
i'm willing to bet he'd fire fouchy
right away
it sounds like political persecution if
a president gets in and starts arresting
his enemies
i mean people who broke the law
yeah lots of them a lot of them are
breaking the law right there's a lot of
documents they should be arrested all
the executives it's not illegal when the
president does it that's it trump
trump also just a couple days ago said
it's hard to criticize biden now because
biden congratulated him on his promotion
of the vaccine oh my god so there's also
that as well and then donald trump also
doubled down and
made veiled attacks against ron desantis
the governor of florida for not publicly
talking about his booster shot allegedly
that he took according to trump who's
attacking him now um
it was only a matter of time until the
two people butted heads
i'm not saying trump will be right to do
it i'm not saying trump is correct in
every action he's taken i'm saying trump
will get an office and be like this is
my one chance i'm not gonna play around
i've learned from the mistakes i've made
and and he's just gonna say i want the
documents released release him now and
he's gonna he's gonna so he's gonna walk
with these people he's gonna say i'm
gonna follow you to the to the archives
and i'm gonna watch you publicly release
these documents right now under my
orders as president because when he
would do all this stuff last time they'd
be like you got it and then they
wouldn't do it and then trump would
forget about it
he is going to go off
the rails he is going to be like i'm not
playing games anymore he strikes me like
a really bright hot fire that's burning
off of like not a lot of fuel like uh
paper and it's really really intense but
if the wind blows it just goes out and
you're like where was he when we needed
him where was he when assange was is
rotting away in prison where was he when
when his daughter came crying to bomb a
country so he did it like we need
strength and and yeah you know
consistency i i don't want this
bombastic loud i hear you're not a clown
show anymore i i hear you on that i mean
i i i've often said i'd meet all these
people who would say i voted for trump
because i liked his policies but man i
wish the guy would shut up
but i will also add
i think there's going to be a lot of
people in 2023 a lot of people have
suffered under joe biden the democrats
in the past year the lockdowns have been
miserable
kids are are upset children have
committed suicide i know a guy whose kid
took his life and it's a horrifying
story because he got locked down and
they didn't see it coming
these people
many of them are just going to want
revenge and are you going to get revenge
with ron desantis i'm sorry the answer
is no ron desantis is younger he's
calmer he's collected he's got a lot of
things right a lot of people like him
but donald trump would be like
unleashing a bowl but this time the ball
is on fire that's a good point uh this
claiming
this kind of anger and redemption
because i was just going to bring up
desantis again because i think desantis
is going to give trump a run for his
money i think a lot of people like
desantis a lot more than they like trump
i think there's a lot of broken promises
of trump i think there's also a lot of
clear corruption a lot of promotion of
big pharma when on the other hand you
have desantis that has essentially
stopped the narrative in its tracks when
it was donald trump that said it's only
going to be two weeks to slow the spread
it was donald trump that instituted warp
speed it was donald trump that you know
said here's here fauci control the
country do whatever you want when
desantis did completely the utter
opposite of that and i think when it
comes to that revenge that aspect is
going to be hindered by the fact that
donald trump caused a lot of the pain
that the american people are suffering
with that the democrats continued uh by
continuing his policies while desantis
was one of the only people standing in
the way of it and saying no i'm not
going to implement your mandates i'm not
going to implement your lockdowns your
restrictions your bull crap on my people
because i believe in personal freedom
and personal liberty and because he made
that stand i do believe he's going to
win out against donald trump in the
larger public opinion luke just wants us
to move to florida that's why i love
florida so i am biased here uh from my
perspective and desantis isn't perfect
there's also some things you could
criticize him on but by and large you
see florida leading the way against the
lockdowns the mandates texas was
following very closely what florida was
doing but florida was the first one that
initiated a lot of these major moves
that absolutely broke this coveted
narrative that actually broke a lot of
this nonsense and stopped it in its
tracks and that's why i do believe
desantis and trump are fighting already
it's going to be a big fight it's going
to be a fight that's going to be very
entertaining but at the end of the day i
think desantis absolutely has this one
in the bag yeah trump has a lot of
baggage when it comes to lockdowns and
it when it comes to vaccine mandates i i
think you know he's he is as you
mentioned he's the guy that platformed
fouchy
and if you go back and and look at what
was going on at the time he really got
sort of led around by all of these these
healthcare bureaucrats that absolutely
wanted to impose this radical new
experiment on the american people
and with combine that with the fact that
he wants credit for the vaccine
he's going to say a lot of dumb stuff
about it right now and i think i think i
think desantis looks a hell of a lot
better in that particular argument
and and desantis did it and and trump
talked about he like his first instinct
was right and
and you know when they first said oh
let's shut down the economy trump's like
we can't do that
but then then the bureaucrats convinced
him yeah two weeks to sell the spread
that's how it started with the trump
administration people don't get that do
you think donald trump would rather
solve like heal everybody of covid but
no one knew it was him forever no one
and anybody got the credit or have
people suffer for another year and then
slowly come out of it and then he gets
the credit
it's all about credit i think it's all
about credit psychopath
that's insane yeah well you can't get an
assumption someone agreed with you and
all of a sudden you're like that proves
it like
it's a hypothetical he cares more about
what people think than about getting the
job done when it comes to the vaccine he
wants to credit for it
i think that's trump derangement
syndrome i certainly think trump is
egotistical you're right i'm making an
assumption that of what he thought and
it's like yo
he wants credit for the even even joe
biden i would imagine if someone came to
him and said i am the great fairy joe
biden and i will cure everyone of their
elements but trump will get the credit i
still think biden would be like biden's
trash too anyway i know but i'm saying
like
this get in front of public safety is
the idea the idea of the cartoon villain
i don't believe
is real for the most part yeah you know
it's like
i'd rather everyone suffer you know i
don't think trump no it's not it's not a
i don't think it's a cartoon and i think
um the problem with politics and
politicians
is that they face incentives where the
if they if they get credit for things
they win and if they don't get credit
they lose and and nobody wants to lose
in politics because the whole point is
winning so the very nature
of the process of politics is corrupting
and it's it's based on ego and arrogance
and fatal conceit and and and trump is
sort of a
he he is sort of leans into that
caricature but he's not he's not all
that different than all these guys but
he's a military commander in chief at
that point and when the george floyd
riots broke out day two i said to tim we
gotta get the national guard in there
now and it didn't happen day two day
three still no national guard and then
people started getting shot
and and he didn't want to get called a
fascist trump didn't want people to
think he was a militant fascist so he
didn't send in the national guard he
just let things burn
that's tough
i mean i don't know what the right
answer is he's
well there's a lot of people that he's
mentally
he cares more about the way people
perceive him than giving john let me
bring up this story i think there's a
very real possibility that we don't even
see an opportunity for trump to be
reelected following this news
from timcast.com oath keepers leader and
10 members charged with seditious
conspiracy over january 6 and there it
is
we we heard from marjory taylor green
that there was going to be an attempt to
disqualify members of congress and maybe
even the president himself
there's now an organization out of north
carolina filing a lawsuit saying that
madison cawthorne is no longer
he's disqualified from running for
reelection because he incited
insurrection against the united states
now they have their sedition charges
finally and a lot of people were saying
all throughout last year and we've even
said this there's no insurrection
charges trespassing come on well you
know what i think now
i think they sat on these charges
because they wanted to make sure
sedition was fresh in the minds of the
american public
in an election year
and so here we go yep they're going to
ramp up they're going to start claiming
c it was sedition therefore anyone who
participated in the rally anyone who
helped organize or in any way was
associated with it you have committed in
incited insurrection and you can't hold
office they're going to go after trump
they're going to go after marjorie
taylor greene and they are they're
already going after medicine caught
foreign more people anybody who's who's
opposing the establishment well the
timing here is very odd it took him one
year one year to to press charges i mean
what was going on here this is extremely
unusual to the point where a lot of
people were saying well the oath keepers
they must be fed stewart rhodes is
definitely a fed well now he's getting
some serious you know federal charges
which it doesn't look like he's he's a
fed here but but again one year
does it i i see it's just mind-boggling
kenzinger was like ray epps was only
telling people to go into the the
capital he didn't do it himself so
that's fine but trump held a rally where
he said be strong and that's incitement
you know this guy's a crackpot but you
can you can see that it's it's it's
agenda-driven and the ray epps thing
that's his name right yeah
uh really screwed him over it really
threw him for a loop and they're freak
they can't figure out how to deal with
that guy for those aren't familiar this
is the guy he's seen in a bunch of
videos saying he's telling everyone to
go into the capitol and people are
wondering why he wasn't criminally
charged and now it's at the forefront
and they have no answer there's people
calling them feds the day before the
event because he was calling for
violence and destruction of government
property before the event during the
event he's on camera calling for
property destruction and storming the
capital people are chanting fed fed
and thomas massey uh basically streamed
this video from his phone when he was
talking to the who was he talking to the
head of the the attorney general
um and and then ted cruz picked it up um
i i think i find glenn greenwald's
analysis of this pretty compelling that
it would be quite typical for um
the government to do this kind of thing
but i think in terms of the politics of
it i think it's pretty weak sauce going
into the election
going back to my earlier point
if you're looking at empty grocery
shelves and you can't afford to feed
your family and maybe you've been forced
out of your job because of a vaccine
mandate
all the drama about january 6. and i i
was
super critical
of anyone that participated in january 6
and i i wouldn't apologize for anybody
that
was either committing violence or or
being near it you just don't do that
right
um them up yeah but that's charged yeah
but that said
um this is not the democratic solution
to surviving the re-election
but they think it is they think it is
what what else have they got and i get
it they're gonna double down and this
this this looks fundamentally political
and and they're going to play their
cards and see what happens if they
succeed or i got to be honest if they
even try these lawsuits to disqualify
members of congress and they already are
so i don't even know what i'm saying at
this point but i just think you're
asking for serious trouble in this
country
because what happens when you get a
judge who says we agree matt you get
some you get some lefty establishment
judge and they say we hear your case we
agree madison cawthorn you can't run for
re-election
what do you think the right's gonna do
you think they're gonna be like oh well
gee i guess we can't have our
representative anymore or do you think
they're gonna be like screw you no and
then what happens when you start getting
congressional districts where there's no
agreement on what the proper ballots are
because certain names have been removed
from only some of them
what happens when you get one precinct
saying you can't disqualify him that's
wrong we support him what happens when
republican areas in the district all
defend him and democratic areas refuse
then what
what happens when they actually re-elect
them and then the democrats are just
like look at this court ruling he can't
you cited insurrection under the 14th
amendment section 3 and they do it
anyway do you think people just sit back
and say ah lost this one i guess we'll
carry on no
no no i don't they're going to scream
the courts have ruled he can't run
they're cheating they're breaking the
law and the right's going to say your
ridiculous lawsuit is meritless and the
judge is wrong and there's going to be
no agreement on what the law actually is
supposed to be at that point yeah i
think that's a credible theory to
definitely kind of look at and examine
here especially with the justice
department announcing a new task force
for domestic terrorism the dhs also made
some very alarming statements yesterday
about domestic bomb production so you
know
it might not be enough politically but
that doesn't mean that there's something
uh later down the line that still might
happen that they have planned uh to work
in a bigger political favor so you know
there's some people talking about the
possibility of false flag domestic you
know attacks here in the united states
to blame the right and and the way
things are moving they're really moving
in a very negative way where we are only
becoming more divided uh people are
having more hatred for their fellow
american and the ingredients that are
causing that the corporate media the
social the social media i don't see
those ingredients going away i see them
only being added more into this larger
stirring pot of these globalist elites
that want us all fighting and attacking
each other but you don't have to eat out
of that stewpot that's the key is to get
away from that propaganda and away from
the hatred and away from the fear and
away from a lot of the bull crap but but
if if there's going to be larger staged
events that create you know
victims and casualties
it's going to be very hard for a lot of
people to ignore those kind of large how
do you help people keep an open eyeball
for that kind of stuff
it's very difficult um
it's it's not easy i mean there's a lot
of things working behind the scenes that
we we aren't even privy to we don't even
know about um
and that's that's asking how do you put
a genie back in a genie bottle you gotta
you gotta do something that i've tried
to do i've been super involved in
politics for most of my career i was a
tea party organizer and and i did a rand
paul super pac i did a gary johnson
super pac
and and what we've tried to do
is leave all of that aside
and you know the original aspiration for
for us at free the people was to be sort
of trans partisan try to find
common american values it could bring
people together on various subjects and
see if we couldn't just get along on
something
and and i think the first step of that
is like if you if you go into this
saying you know what i'm team red
i'm red pilled
those other guys are monsters
it doesn't really work that way
um so i've i've tried to to spend some
time talking to my progressive opponents
on some of these issues
i got to say that lockdowns have kind of
blown that up
because now we all really hate each
other and it's very difficult to find
that common ground but but again the
future the anti-authoritarian future
we're going to find people across the
political spectrum
that are fed up with all this crap
and want to do something different we
talk about the left and the right and
then when i look at the political
compass there's actually an up and a
down where the authoritarians you can
have a leftist authoritarian or rightist
authoritarian but then when you go down
you get to the individualism and so you
do see leftist individualists and
righteous individualists i think one of
them i think the left
uh overwhelmingly is authoritarian there
are very few people among democrats who
are anti-authoritarian i'm wondering if
the line on this quad graph isn't
straight lines but actually as it goes
to the left it naturally tends up
towards authoritarianism and as it goes
towards the right it tends down towards
there is visualism there is a such thing
as left libertarianism but it's
substantially uh
less populated because it's a very weird
political space
when it comes to
the modern version of the left uh what
we have in the united states today with
the democratic party and leftist
activists is because they're
overwhelmingly collectivist
even the the the democratic activists or
progressives or dsa types who don't like
biden would support him due to tribalism
and collectivism then you have the
run-of-the-mill lay democratic voter who
doesn't know anything but adheres to the
authority out of ignorance and fear so
it's not that they're authoritarian
these people in the sense that they're
you know like we want you to bend the
knee and do as you're told it's that
they don't know anything don't want to
know anything and say i'm gonna do what
i'm told by brian stelter and jake tap
authoritarian follower as opposed to an
authoritarian leader yeah yeah i mean i
figure there's an audience i mean
there's there's people hardset in their
ways and
and maybe it has something to do with
age where you just stop thinking about
the world anymore you you are who you
are and you've accepted that but i think
there's an opportunity particularly with
young people i'm trying to be an
optimist here so hang out with me for
just a second
i think a lot of young people are
searching for something else and i think
there is a small l libertarian solution
where we can sort of accommodate our
different cultural differences and you
can be conservative you can be liberal
you can be all these different things
as long as we agree to solve problems on
the local level
and live our lives however we see fit as
long as you don't hurt people or take
their stuff
and and that ultimately is the
libertarian solution i'm i'm i'm selling
t-shirts too tonight sorry it says don't
hurt people and don't take their stuff
yeah i agree with that
it's a simple message that i wish more
people would just understand and and
that's literally
a lot of people's philosophies that that
if they instituted would would create
such a better world yeah just don't
steal that's that's it but it's got to
be like i don't think that's a political
solution you're talking about changing
hearts and minds
and talking about a little bit of
humility when we deal with other people
who who may be confused about using the
power of state to force other people to
be vaccinated
for people whose minds are still open we
should talk to them
and and that's the opportunity here for
for people that are hardened
authoritarians
you can't they're well they're done
here's a question that transforms them
what on this show you know that you may
have seen or you guys has been
conservative
is saying defy the state and the
authority is that conservative no no
absolutely not uh
opposing vex mandates is that a
conservative position
no that's a tribal political position i
guess it's a liberty position it's
interesting to me that many of the
people we're trying to convince
have this view that this show is
conservative when we almost we rarely if
ever talk about like abortion and taxes
and
traditional family values or anything
like that yet somehow
that's that's that's what we're accused
of being that's what they say when our
discussions are almost always
libertarian you could argue i think that
opposing vast mandates is conservative
because it's like this weird liberal
thing that where they want to change the
whole way the system's built and we're
like yo natural immunity is a thing
there's other ways let's not rush this
that's not concern that's kind of like
the let's let's
conserve our energy let's slowly move
through this traditional conservatism is
uh and feel free to chime in after i say
this
my interpretation is upholding
traditional values that help preserve a
system that has led to success
that would be
protect the system
defend the status quo
and then progressivism or leftism is the
way it's we've usually described it is
the left pulls towards progress and the
right holds them back a little bit and
they slowly move towards you know new
ways of doing things but not too much
too fast and what we've got now is the
chain is snapped the right is stumbling
back a little bit only a little bit and
the left has just taken off running like
you know the dog getting loose on the
leash
so i don't see anything that we're
talking about being conservative because
we're actually fairly reformist we're
complaining about the establishment
we're actually revolutionary we call for
the end of the federal reserve so how is
any of that that's amazing the federal
reserve is is a revolutionary
is a revolutionary idea that's wild and
they would be like it's a conservative
show i'm like bro you guys are defending
massive multinational corporations how
we convince those people
i honestly
we can we can tell the truth we can be
honest but short of using their tactics
and manipulation i don't see how you you
change people's minds
that's a good one i don't know music
like i i don't i don't think we followed
the authoritarians paradigm because
their their
whole role is to manipulate
and scare people into falling in line
and our model is is more like joe rogan
let's have a conversation i'm not here
to tell you what to think but i'm going
to insist that you start thinking for
yourself
and to me that's our paradigm and i know
it sounds a little hippy dippy but um
we're not going to out authoritarian
authoritarians we gotta we gotta figure
out a totally different way to engage
people
and i think people that have gone
through this this two years of
of of lockdown torture and all the
psychological and personal damage we've
done particularly to children
i think people might be hungry for an
alternative
and and we're that revolution but i
think our tactics are different we
respect people enough not to tell them
well so this is the funny thing right
the uh historical left and right you
guys are you familiar with originates
the french revolution right where the
people sitting on the right were the
they were the monarchists or the you
know they wanted to keep the systems
aristocracy yeah and then the left was
the revolutionary communist lefty types
the funny thing is we're sitting here
saying the establishment is busted and
broken they're bad we got to vote them
all out get rid of that we want to end
the fed we want dramatic revolutionary
change in this country and the quote
unquote left people like hassan or vosh
are saying the massive multinational
corporations are correct and we should
be forced to buy their products by the
status quo establishment politicians and
i'm like that makes them right wing yeah
it doesn't matter if your economic
position is nationalization of a
corporation
you are his on the historical scale
based on the original definition the
right wing defending aristocracy and
we're here complaining about it fascist
absolute fascist even occupy democrats
they tweeted today that in greece the
government is fining people 113 dollars
per month because they didn't take a
product from a private criminal
multinational organization they're also
bragging that in austria the government
is finding people stealing four thousand
dollars for them because they didn't
take a product from a big pharma agency
this is also going to be happening in
quebec and occupy democrats are asking
retweet if you want this to happen in
the united states which is absolutely
ridiculous they're on the side of
literally forcing you through the threat
of stealing your money or having guys
show up with guns and use violence
against you if you don't buy a product
this is where they're at they're
absolutely fascists totalitarian
technocrats that have no respect for
human decency or your personal property
i have a i have a tweet about this so uh
here we have the tweet they say greece
announces that it'll begin
finding the unvaccinated 113 dollars per
month austria announces that it'll begin
finding them for four thousand finding
them four thousand a month and quebec
announces it may begin slapping them
with a significant fine retweet if you
think america must do it my response was
no
we should just lock the unvaccinated
people in jail they can leave any time
as soon as they get the vaccine this way
we aren't forcing them to get vaccinated
and we keep people safe australia model
i was concerned about that tweet because
they're gonna take your advice
so i i often tweet
uh garbled nonsense but i have no
problem explaining why i do it
by tweeting the opposite in a slightly
slightly silly way
the average person of intelligence
understands my point and you can't take
the tweet and assert context to it
so
i luke posted a meme and i'm like i'm
looking at this meme and it's like you
know questioning you know vaccines and
things like that or it's the science and
the corporations around it
and i'm like if you post that they might
say you're posting medical
misinformation and ban you so i posted
it
very in a very silly way criticizing it
and pushing something that was absurd so
what are they going to do they going to
ban me for saying it was crazy yeah and
though most people understand my point
my response to this tweet was replying
to it with a gif of mussolini giving a
speech i saw that that was awesome like
that's also another way just mocking
these people because their ideas are
absurd and when we really break it down
what they're doing they're calling for
violent men with guns to come to people
and steal their money for not taking a
product that's essentially what it boils
down to and so let me just let's let me
just stress this point right now and i'm
going to say it again to make sure
everyone here says i really want the
bread tubers to hear this
if we are talking about the french
revolution and the right was as you
described would say the aristocracy and
the left was the revolutionary
we sit before you today as humble civil
libertarians and big el libertarians in
a certain sense saying the establishment
politici politicians are corrupt and
broken the massive multinational
corporations are criminal and they are
stripping the value and the rights of
the working class in this country
we believe that there needs to be
dramatic revolutionary change in this
country like ending the federal reserve
not depending on chinese slave labor and
not just ending the fed we would repeal
it and then take control of the finances
with our congress restoring the rights
of the working class ending the corrupt
aristocracy and elitism in this nation
and letting good working-class people
have the fruits of their labor from the
labor they produce
and many of you
many of you sit there and say it is good
that nancy pelosi and joe biden corrupt
neo-neocon corporatists neolib
corporatists are mandating the american
people be forced to buy a product from a
massive multinational corporation
you are the right in your own argument
and we are the left we are to the left
of you and we're not even leftists
now if you want to talk about economic
scale when left means economic policy
collectivism or right is laissez-faire
then we'll have an argument for sure but
if you want to play that game of left
and right as tribes
y'all on the on bread tube are actually
right wing for defending the government
and the corporations as they do this how
does that happen isn't that weird they
must have changed aisles there at some
point they all got up and and shuffled
over i think that's that's why you got
to not get too hung up on the
definitions of the words rightist and
leftists because really yeah these
you can call yourself whatever you want
but if you're supporting multinational
corporate takeover that's authoritarian
as hell you know it's monarchist as hell
criminal entities with no liability for
their product that's forced and extorted
on the general public that's a whole new
level of craziness that has a criminal
past of of buying off regulators
politicians and doctors for pure profit
motive that they had to pay billions of
dollars in fines too pfizer is like in
the top 10 largest criminal uh cases in
the world yeah pfizer's like number five
or six or something for buying off
regulators scientists and politicians
you know in practice it's it's quite
often difficult to see the difference
between fascist regimes and communist
regimes
and one technically is government
ownership of the means of production the
other is government control of the means
of production but
i've i've done a pretty deep dive on
this and if you look at pol pot
uh the mass murder in cambodia
and you look at many of his policies not
just economics but but civil liberties
and general disdain for life
it's fairly difficult to tell the
difference between him and adolf hitler
and yet we're taught that these guys are
in opposite ends of the the political
spectrum no they're both murderous
authoritarians
and and my my mine's different than you
i put the bad guys on the bottom
i get the the metaphor of putting us on
the bottom but uh as you move up my
political scale you get to
all the things that are voluntary
cooperation and choice
and and informed consent
and all these crazy radical ideas that
that neither political establishment
will tolerate today and to me
it goes back to your your manifesto that
you laid out there that's
that's where we can find reasonable
people and it almost feels like it's in
the middle even though it's outside of
the current structure altogether it's
the people that spin around all through
it and are willing to engage and
understand all of it that are seem like
they're in the middle it's happening so
fast that it just looks like it's it's
right there yeah those are the people
i'm looking for
well i think we found them tonight
in the comments
or they're all saying we're foolish
no i think um
the people who watch tend to be fairly
moderate
you know nobody's an extremist in in you
know
in any sense maybe a few people pop in
here and there we get some leftists who
just hate us and they're very
authoritarian you know tanky types but
for the most part you know the people i
meet on the street regular people and
they're just you know the response i
usually get from people is they're like
i don't know man i just want to be able
to to live to feed my family to get by i
don't want to hurt anybody i don't want
to i don't want to cause problems i just
want things to get better and i want
people to chill out yeah that's a lot of
it
you got a lot of people who are like we
want to go crazy we want to go to war we
want dramatic revolutionary change by
any means necessary and you know the the
one thing i find fascinating because
i've talked to a lot of antibiotic
people about this
i said isn't the use of violence against
someone inherently authoritarian
and they just they never have a real
answer for it you might get these
sophists who are like actually the use
of violence isn't because and i'm like
what about beating someone until they
agree with you is not authoritarian
because is it authoritarianism strict
adherence to the authority or or
governance or politics um based upon
adherence to the authority and the use
of violence is authoritarian to force
them to do it whereas libertarian would
be like sitting down over a cup of
coffee and having a discussion and an
argument and trying to convince them
persuasion right well defense of
violence i guess could be a libertarian
thing
in uh you know we have this thing called
the non-aggression principle that if you
you can't mess with somebody else but if
they mess with you they threaten your
your life or your property you have a
right to defend yourself
um but but back to your point i think
this is super important
antifa's model is explicitly violent
they're quite proud of it and and they
think that violent change is the only
way to sort of transform society break
the system
and you know all of these all of these
communist dictators tried this stuff and
they they didn't give one damn about
human life
our strategy has to be the difference
different fundamentally different ours
has to be non-violent because violence
is the ultimate violation of of
liberties and
and people's humanity so
i think there's power
in non-violence and i'm a student i'm a
student of martin luther king
and gandhi and i've studied these
non-violent movements the solidarity
movement
um who would have thought
that a bunch of guys could gather
and beat
this all-powerful soviet regime with
non-violence they did it
so i i think our tactics have to be
different
and which is why i was so critical about
january 6th
um aping the other guys
is a losing strategy you're saying with
the soviet is is the peace what was the
party name you said that defied the
soviets solidarity movement it was a
movement of union workers and people
coming together throughout the factories
that they were mandated to work at
saying no we're going to protest we're
not going to work for the soviet empire
we're going to strike and because of
those strikes and that kind of
collective collective bargaining power
it was one of the reasons out of many
why the soviet empire kind of crumbled
and for those which my family was a part
of in dinosaur poland and a little bit
of trivia for you guys for those that
are fans of the game civilization in the
video game civilization 2 which is a
very early version of it
you're you're you're creating a country
when you have civil unrest it actually
shows an image from the solidarity
movement they're holding the big sign
and protesting and that's the symbol
used in the game of unrest in your city
yeah cool stuff huh
a lot of history there um and it shows
you that protests throughout history
sometimes do work now there's a lot of
peasants that say protests never work
but i think it's worth a try and i
definitely agree with you we should we
should always strive to be non-violent
we should also have the ability to
defend ourselves if if the need comes
but prioritize that non-violence over
anything else because the state has
mastered the tool of of of anger of
hatred and of violence in such a way
that there's no using it in any way that
it doesn't benefit them directly but
there is a big protest coming um as it
is just about a week it is in dc what is
the protest called like the march
against mandates is it are you sure it's
called march against manchester no but
that's what i think it is yeah i don't
think that's the point so we have this
story from newsweek
joe rogan and robert kennedy jr to speak
at conspiracy theorist vaccine mandate
protest
wow what a story newsweek you and palmer
or how do you pronounce your name i
wonder where you got that information i
reached out to joe rogan for comment and
i said are you going to this thing he
said no and that was it i'm like why are
they reporting he's going to this um but
i suppose it's easier for me to ask him
because i know him than it was for this
journalist but where the hell did they
get this information to claim he was
going to be there i had to wonder
because when i saw this i was like if i
tell people joe's not going to be there
less people will show up right because
if they genuinely thought joe would be
there i mean you might fill a stadium
with people showing up
is it possible this guy was like i'm
just going to say it because then
everyone's going to want to be there
we saw it occupy wall street they
claimed radiohead was coming and
thousands like ten thousand how many
people were there luke like ten thousand
it was it was ridiculous huge coming yep
but everyone was there right before they
were about to allegedly sweep the park
and kick everyone out they say he is
listed as being among the speakers at
the march which ends the lincoln
memorial
so
where where does that come from um
probably some fake news probably either
someone trying to make sure that more
people show up to this protest i mean
we're talking about this protest now
i think it's a worthwhile protest i
don't know who sent them the information
obviously brett weinstein is also
weinstein is also making sure that
people understand that this is kind of
fake news being spread out there uh but
there's going to be a lot of important
people out there i think it's an
important protest i think it's an
important discussion that needs to be
had in this country um
as far as this fake news i don't really
have anything else to say other than
that i'm sure i'm sure uh both people
that want people to show up and people
that want to demonize this thing are
going to be um spreading a lot of
information
i for one would love to see
americans stand up and rise up and i've
been i've been disappointed that we
haven't seen the same sort of massive
marches we're all on twitter and we're
watching these marches all across europe
um in australia everywhere
and there's been less of it in the
united states and i think we're due
for a nice grassroots uprising but i
would i would again say i'm going to
beat this dead horse it's got to be
peaceful because everybody's watching
and one bad actor will will destroy your
message and and and transform what what
could be
a pivotal moment in american history and
the feds are dying for an incident to
happen that will turn violent that will
hurt other people that will work in
their benefits so they desperately want
something like to ha
want something like that to happen i
would even say as desperate as to even
potentially manufacture it that's my
person so it is it is defeat the
mandates dc
and they say
after they get the lincoln memorial
recording artists prominent doctors
journalists pro athletes actors and
premier thought leaders will give a
series of inspiring talks and musical
performances i don't see if it says who
is going to be there though or why they
were claiming that it was going to be
just open it looks like the the flccc
has also provided a lot of important
information to a lot of people that
even information that i personally use
myself
and they do a lot of good work so it's
cool to see them involved here uh chris
martinson of peak prosperity is also
going to be there he's going to be
speaking and participating he's uh you
know he's been on the show he's a friend
of mine as well dr malone dr mccullough
um and i'm not sure about robert kennedy
jr i don't know if he's confirmed does
conspiracy mean anything anymore it
doesn't mean anything does it the media
is just like a conspiracy march and i'm
like that doesn't mean anything i
literally don't care what you think you
are all crackpots you believe the
covington kid bs imagine taking medical
advice from people who believe jesse
smallette sorry the moment you said that
i'm just like bro i don't care what you
have to say about conspiracy theories at
all literally the the spoiler alert uh
yeah march would be a more appropriate
name for what's been happening here um
and again the corporate media is going
to vilify it because it goes against a
lot of their corporate media partners
and uh this is bad for business for the
big industries that are tied to them so
obviously they're going to try to attack
it in any way that they can it's only a
matter of time before we get that email
where it's like hi i'm with pfizer and
we'd love to sponsor your show
and then all of a sudden one day we're
like you know what we're totally in
favor of this people should get 12.
12 vaccines talk to your doctor about
your 12th vaccine today oh my gosh no no
we won't we won't play those games it'd
be interesting to do a fiser ad and then
at the end after the ad be like yeah
pfizer's trash this authoritarian
corporation like i wonder if that'd be
that'd be good that'd be fun if i ever
received anything where it was like we'd
like to sponsor your show i'd probably
just publish all the documents and i'm
saying that now so it'll definitely
never happen but i would thoroughly
enjoy being like thank you for the
request here's here twitter here's what
they're sending people i would love to
see uh tim poole brought to you by
pfizer
all of a sudden i'm wearing a suit yeah
we're in a different room pfizer beanie
we're in an office building we're all
wearing uh you know
black tie suits
luke's pronouncing everything
pronouncing everything correctly it's
just
it's bizarro pfizer world right yeah
well i'll say this uh
luke you're going to be at the protest
yes
i got to tell everybody be careful
because agent provocateurs man
absolutely that's why it's important to
live stream i'm going to be probably
live streaming if i could get good cell
phone signal and videotaping everything
making sure that of course we get
everything on the record because the
only thing really preventing and
stopping something is being fully
transparent open uh and honest about
everything and the best way to do that
is to live stream so i'm going to be
live streaming on youtube.com forward
slash i'll just say if i was there at a
protest and i saw someone something like
this trying to act before get violent i
would stop them
i would and and we saw that there was a
lot of this some of this went on there's
really cool videos there was a guy who
was ripping bricks off out of the
sidewalk oh yeah and then activists left
the activists grabbed him and dragged
him to the police and they were like get
him out of here we do not want this and
then the cops even let one of the guys
go like he got caught up in and they're
like okay you're cool and they arrested
the guy who was vandalizing stuff that's
what you need to see
now i don't know what people should do
for legal reasons i have no idea so talk
to the organizers but don't let people
do any of that crazy stuff because you
will get some anti-foot type who's going
to show up wearing a manga hat and be
like i'm going to make them all look
crazy that's the problem is someone
could go there put on a manga hat and
throw a brick and then
that gives the government authority to
like send in troops
one guy can do that that's crazy so we
did we dealt with this and this is
before smartphones were such a thing but
i was a tea party organizer and we
organized that massive march
in 2009 on the mall
and and you know no arrests no violence
um a couple kids got lost we found them
again it was like this beautiful
uh bottom-up thing but eventually
people that wanted to
sort of smear a reputation showed up and
and one of the tactics we used which i
believe we borrowed from the left was we
created signs that said this guy's not
with us
and we would surround a bad actor and we
don't know if the guy's
a bad actor from our side or their side
but if the behavior's wrong
if they were if they were doing
something violent or something racist we
would just surround them and and they
would just leave yeah because they were
outed
and it's it's hard to police
a grassroots movement and the way that
mlk did it with his march on washington
it was very carefully scripted the signs
were created
by the organizers that's not how it
works anymore so you've got to figure
out some way
to police your own community you have
zero tolerance for bad behavior no
matter who's doing it
what do you guys think is going to
happen
peaceful massive how many people you
think some people are estimating a
hundred thousand but i think those are
uh over inflated numbers and you usually
you usually see numbers over
over-inflated but at the same time we
haven't seen a protest here in the
united states for a very long time
compare that to what's been happening in
france in austria in australia in
germany in the united kingdom there have
been massive protests with tens of
thousands of people some instances even
hundreds of thousands of people coming
to the streets saying enough is enough
and i think just being able to see that
kind of larger representation does have
some kind of larger political change and
does
put into people's minds that they're not
alone and i think that's that's
important and i think peaceful peaceful
rallying and peaceful protests are
extremely important and uh you know who
knows what's gonna happen but
um i'm gonna be there to see it's winter
we got a snowstorm coming this weekend
i'm not
i don't want to be debbie downer but i'm
not confident i was just go like in my
brain i was like i was just going just
going to call you a debbie downer uh we
were supposed to go hiking for like so
long and tim's like no it's going to
rain it's raining no we're going now
it's not raining now we're supposed to
go hiking this weekend and tim's like oh
it's going to snow we're not going i'm
like fake news we're going to go anyway
no it's not it's true news it's
absolutely true news let me tell you let
me tell you the facts the first was
actually raining it was literally
raining outside and luke said who cares
let's go anyway and i said bro
it says it's going to keep raining until
pm yes
i don't think it's it's good to drive
two hours
and then just be like well it was
raining and we knew it was raining and
then waste the day driving two hours
back as it turns out the rain stopped
where where luke ended up going hiking
and he was fine
the only thing that really happened was
i wasn't willing to take the risk and
luke was and it benefited luke that's
the true news stop being fake news i
keep telling you the the the the weather
reports keep lying to you man just like
the media does
and then even if it is raining it'll
still be an interesting hike to go on we
just bring weather gear and still enjoy
the hike rather than just now
here's the false framing from luke while
we were going to go hiking this weekend
there is a report that a major winter
storm is coming so what we said was how
about we go snowboarding or skiing
instead so we still go up to the
mountain we still get the views and luke
said no no when then he had nothing now
that's fake news that's fake news on
your part i never said no on that part
you want to you want to go like next
weekend and well yeah because uh it's
it's a couple hour drive through the
snow we have to stay the night but luke
you work sundays and then
you know just but that's that's that's
the truth you know luke trying to smear
me and
trying to pull a pull a daily beast over
here you got me thinking though that if
someone does decide to co-opt the
weather system and want to give us the
fake news that's a good way because
people trust that implicitly i've never
heard anyone question the weather even
when uh just this past weekend they said
it was gonna rain and then it didn't
rain i'm telling you leave it there's no
reason to believe the news tim somebody
there was actually a meteorologist who
pointed this out he said when they were
predicting this big winter storm he was
like the the weather the weather system
is in the in the pacific ocean there's
no way you can accurately predict what
it's going to do in the next two weeks
so
i guess uh
it is still for the most part coming
true in a lot of ways it's not the same
as the projection from two weeks ago
obviously but we're supposed to get hit
with a big winter storm we're supposed
to get very very heavy snowfall out here
so
you know that that is bad news for us
because fortunately it's happening over
the weekend but it usually means that
it's harder to get out here so we'll
have to figure that stuff out you know
drive safely everyone yeah yep yep in
the middle of nowhere and the power
could go out yikes exciting but how
about we go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this youtube channel right
now by clicking that little subscribe
button or uh or the podcast if you're
listening on the podcast and go to
timcast.com become a member
and you will get access to our members
only podcast they go up around 11 or so
p.m monday through thursday we're gonna
have one and this is uncensored we swear
a lot we talk about spicy things and we
just
we just we just go for it uncensored
it's so much fun so become a member
check those out let's read what you guys
have to say over in the super chats
all right the first super chat i'm sorry
i can't read your name because youtube
blocks it for some reason they say let's
start the show off right smash that like
button that's right excellent tim we're
about to breed our nigerian dwarf goats
and you're going to get the first baby
goat uh i will accept the baby goats are
awesome i lived uh with goats in new
hampshire they're really really awesome
to have this package well and just i
think farms yeah i think once we uh
we're maybe four or five months out from
being operational at fridamastan and
we'll probably have goats you like that
luke came up the name
yeah that's that that works for me yeah
yeah
did you get the url because that's
everything uh i think we have it yeah
yeah yeah got it and we're gonna get uh
like when you drive in there's gonna be
a big sign that says free damascan
and i assume that laphroaig 25 will just
pour from the faucets that's correct for
people who like whiskey yeah uh we're
gonna have a passport control
it's it's just gonna be our security
booth but like you know we're gonna have
the guy act like you know welcome to
freedom stand and you know different
country yeah it's a different it's not
really but i want to set up a bar like a
tap bar with a bunch of different beers
but instead of beer it's a bunch of
different soaps like really good soap so
you can get like your organic lavender i
like that it's actually not a bad idea
for the bathroom that'd be cool to have
like a soap tap where you pull this
thing down yeah yeah well that's a good
idea we should do that that's kind of
that's kind of the end of the long tail
um that's kind of a niche dream that you
have there yeah we'll have like you know
you'll have a raspberry lemon you'll
have the cucumber melon
you'll have the mint yeah the goat's
milk and you'll i'll do a blend today
fine soaps yeah
yeah and we'll put a lot of things on
tap for you all right all right
all right
normies get out says look at me seamus
is the captain now sheamus is not here
well he's here in the building but he's
not here in the studio he's with he's
physically with us he's just on the show
i'll help you on the show at some point
he's doing um
i don't know what what does sheamus do
he's drawing pictures yeah he does all
that he trusts talks on the phone yeah
it makes me laugh talk drawing pictures
of ouchie yeah oh yeah and then he comes
to me and he's like tim can you be
fouchy you're like and then i'm like i
will try i can be
normies god says sheamus cast or no cast
it's shim cass
no we want sheamus shane cast all right
abnormal normal says my wife who is a
nurse just received an email stating she
will no longer have a job if not jabbed
by the 29th i will never shake the hand
of someone on the other side i am now
ready to fight like never before by any
means needed the war is now well
this is this is what we fear because we
don't want that don't let yourself get
radicalized man
but i mean
if if the u.s does break apart then
china just takes over so i like and i
like this you know
bringing back the factories for the
working class and strengthening this
country and maintaining peace and
everything but
if we start fighting each other china's
just going to be like all right time for
global communism you know so as the
economist i have a theory about what all
of these very talented healthcare
workers are about to get fired can do
um you're you're going to create a very
ration system within
any organization that takes medicare
medicaid but there's this thing called
concierge medicine yes there's this
there's this alternative form of
medicine and i think entrepreneurs are
going to scoop these people up and
they're going to make more money and
they're going to practice
medicine
with a modicum of freedom so
don't get depressed don't get desperate
look for that
alternative and i i think we should
encourage everybody to say like let's
take this as a win yeah the system's
firing us so let's go create something
better yeah i didn't know this but um
apparently wealthy people will just hire
doctors what
yeah is that did you know that i did
know that yeah i have heard about that
and like a company so like an oil
company will have a doctor on staff
that's awesome and and the ceo will be
like i need this medication and he'll go
you're right and he'll fill out the
prescription thing and hand it to him
correct and one of those is interesting
one of the things i've been looking at
too is all these uh things that aren't
actually insurance like meta share um
and tom woods has one that he advertises
that i always forget the name of but
these are not technically insurance
companies but they do offer coverage and
they help you do things like they'll
help you like crowdsource your bills
which i think is fantastic so hopefully
some of these people who are fired for
refusing to be vaccinated can go over
and work over there with them something
that's coming too with 3d printing is uh
medical is medicine a lot of it is like
artificial intelligence building up
medicines that are tailor fit for your
body so that you'll get a unique form of
medicine that is specific for you
instead of these top-down mandates of
everyone take the same drug yeah i mean
the upside and and we libertarians are
very difficult to talk about the upside
and we talk all about how the government
has destroyed the health care system
but there's this beautiful world where
where doctors and patients actually get
to make decisions and innovation happens
in innovative economic structures so
that medicine becomes more affordable
i think the same thing is going to
happen in healthcare that is is
happening right now in education where
more and more moms are saying you know
what screw your masks and your vax
mandates
and your your your skype schooling i'm
going to go create a pod
with my neighbors
and and teach my kids in an environment
where they can actually thrive i think
that's the upside of all this downside
is that that people are going to get
innovative
and and practice a little bit of freedom
and um speaking of freedom and
innovation sir weed bong ventura says
i'm unvaxxed and i still pooped my pants
sorry to hear it sir i'm sorry to hear
it try fasting thank you
lay off the chipotle does does vax
does being vacs help you
retain your bowels i think it's a joke
i don't think they're seriously yeah
yeah i am one with the comment section i
appreciate you guys lilly cake says
waukesha native here daryl brooks jr
christmas parade monster preliminary
hearing begins tomorrow 75 plus charges
please do not let this fall off your
radar take care everyone i agree we
absolutely should not allow them to
sweep that story under the rug i loved
all the memes though where it showed the
guy walking and his head was an suv and
it would show like the news headline
where it says suv crashes into people as
if it was just like the machine that did
it i liked the jokes too where it was
like decepticon invades earth you know
suv crashed into people
it wasn't the person who did it no
all right deplorable eye says i have not
seen reports on the supply chain
improving in the next six weeks as the
winter weather continues to worsen how
soon do you expect food rights in major
cities i don't know if we're gonna see
food rights for some time if at all to
be honest hope not but i just um i do
think
with the um
canada backed down on their vacs mandate
for i i don't know it was canada but the
us the canada border had a vast mandate
they backed down on this because
truckers were going to revolt we still
could end up seeing you know vaccinated
at some point but with the supreme court
striking this down
i think things might actually improve a
little bit oh yeah i mean the winter is
going to be a problem the lack of
drivers is a problem but if they if the
supreme court said okay vax mandate this
country would collapse overnight so i
think the supreme court had no choice
you're a very wealthy country and and
the good news about being us is that the
system
the economy and everybody that's that's
actually bringing food to your table
that it mostly still works
and that's not true in every country but
it's true in ours so i i don't expect to
see food riots anytime soon
in large part because of what you just
said
all right brett stubb says just happy
the homie matt is on tim cast an
absolute legend ask him about the dead
abe lincoln gary johnson video good
memories lol oh so we we created a uh
gary johnson super pac ad that featured
a comedian that dressed up like dead abe
lincoln who was the first successful
third-party candidate
and and we claim and i think it's i
think it's mostly true that that was the
most viral ad of 2016.
um trump was super viral hillary spent a
stupid amount of money trying to get
people excited about her and and daddy
blinking killed it dead abe lincoln
all right
jiffer says
tim i saw your episode of cnn's failing
viewership trigger warning only donald
trump can save cnn how many liberals
heads just imploded
that was true though i mean uh before
trump came on twitter twitter was
actually failing they were losing users
like crazy they were changing their
their metrics how they tracked users
because they were trying to make the
numbers look better and then trump came
in and started calling people horse face
and boom twitter all of a sudden was was
was flourishing trump could have left at
any point didn't want to do it
all right
what is this
nalorum would you all grow up and stop
acting like they are just being prudent
major corpse are the only ones pushing
it because they lead by never they're
led by never trumpers they are attacking
political rivals and you are helping
them by pretending to be reasonable i
don't know what that means
we we are not fans of the big
corporations i think it's an
unreasonable accusation against us
yes yes i am i am triggered
and outraged
iggy the incubus says today is a good
day for hope in the words of razor razor
fist accelerationism is just
surrendering with alacrity and the black
pill is an effing suppository
god effing speed to you all at the
beanie compound well i'll tell you this
man
i decided to leave new york
and that was a few years ago and look
where they're at now
i wasn't wrong about that decided to
leave the philly area i wasn't wrong
about that i'm out here in the middle of
nowhere and hopefully not wrong about
this
i could be at any point i have no idea
but i'm really glad i left new york and
i'm not there now
i'm really glad we spent some time in
south jersey but considering what was
going on in philly and the riots i'm
really glad we left
so if
my you know predictions just stay
slightly on track
it's good i think people would be would
would be wise to get out of cities
go find i live in like a state of
existential horror when i look at the
economy uh the inflation like okay i've
done some math in my life i know what's
happening and what's coming when you
look at the way that they're inflating
the economy and what they did before the
great depression just
in fact check out some a documentary on
the great depression if you want to look
at what it looked like leading up to
that that that six weeks of fail or
whatever it was
so tim will you commit to talk to my
wife about this because i still live on
capitol hill and we we desperately need
to get out of there yeah man i mean
we're not that far away yeah it's only
an hour to get out yeah like it's it's
closer than i thought yeah so we got 50
acres and it's only an hour and a half
from dc it's actually really close and
that could be a problem for us but it's
far enough away to where we've got
freedom and space and private land it's
unrestricted and we can still get access
to the airport for guests to come in and
out so that's kind of the compromise do
you hear that terry she's listening
i'm looking straight to camera on this
oh it's cheap man too they got like
there's i was looking at a plot i think
it was like 30 acres for 100k yeah you
got to build on it but you know 30 acres
man
be real says
well people are okay with this half
baked potato as long as the bad orange
man can't tweet mean things anymore
that's correct indeed he is a half baked
potato
okay
jacob villa says in april of 2022 the
international classification of diseases
is introducing new medical codes one is
z28310 unvaccinated for covet 19. i work
in him as a rhia you know that means
lydia i have no idea okay
this is very concerning to me doctors
are now documenting reasons for vax
refusal in their soap notes huh rhi
registered health information
administrator oh there you go okay
doesn't say it sounds medical
glizzy water says for yesterday's from
yesterday's show i became an owner
operator trucker to not have to get the
vacs and it was weird you talked about
truckers as i got off the exit to
harper's ferry today
spooky nice creepy
simulation speaks we have a lot of
listeners that are truckers yeah oh yeah
yeah
what a great show to listen to while
you're
trucking along the united states it's a
couple hours there you go it's supplying
the country it's an important job
without truck people don't realize how
important truckers are
i think it's the most important job in
the country absolutely 100 it's like red
blood cells
delivering the oxygen rate
the resources yes yeah carrying the
oxygen that we need to the to the you
know locations to the organs
and uh it really is that's so wild how
it's fractal and yeah if you ever if
you've ever zoomed out of like a highway
and see all the little trucks moving
back and forth yeah it's like carrying
the resources into and out of it's crazy
it's so cool transporting all the goods
fun stuff and we have to keep the laptop
class fed
yeah yeah absolutely we have to do that
got to bring the food into the buzzfeed
flip-flop wearing yuppies
all right christopher says dude trump
isn't going to get reelected the
republicans are not going to win 2022
now that people have actually been
arrested for sedition the dems are going
to disqualify them mtg told you as much
um
i mean we talked about it a bit but what
do you think you think it'll happen
we'll see i mean no one has a i believe
it is variable at this point depending
on how we act the next couple years
jeffrey says i think ian is right trump
is a fire without enough fuel
who is who's nathan hale oh he was uh
he's a patriot oh yeah one of the
founders we need the nathan hale
attitude i regret that i have but one
life to give for my country he died oh
wow
mel g says can someone make a shirt of
desantis riding a flaming bowl through
the white house i bet it already exists
honestly yeah as soon as we said it
trump will be the flaming bull dragon
lady says didn't think i'd be able to
watch tonight gotta get up early but
then i saw matt was going to be on his
don't hurt people and don't take their
stuff is the best libertarian book of
the last decade also lydia the kitty
mosaic rocks yeah so you have a book
it's the same title it's uh this t-shirt
is stolen from the book number two new
york times best seller don't hurt people
and don't take their stuff libertarian
manifesto hey i looked at the site and
it looks like that particular shirt
right now is sold out do you know when
it might be back um
we actually talked about it this week
it'll it'll be there hold on i want to
order one
overdressed says luke's speech people
who speak many languages often don't
feel the same importance in saying words
in the right way there is no right way
only getting the information and emotion
across he probably speaks polish at home
thank you um i dream polish which is
actually uh pretty pretty weird as well
um so i'm not dyslexic that's that's
it's just sick divided sorry
i have a question uh if you have a dream
and say ian's in it would ian be
speaking polish to you i don't know i'm
not sure do it and let me know yeah
i don't know
i don't think i can manifest my dreams
into my dream world he ends like luke
dream of me but breathe out really slow
sometimes sometimes during english
sometimes they're in polish which is
which is weird but predominantly it's
polish what i'm talking to somebody or
someone's talking to me at home i speak
with my family in polish i was born in
poland i was raised in poland so uh
obviously there's a lot of polish still
in my mind especially when i'm trying to
express ideas uh in you know in such a
quick unscripted way sometimes my
signals get jumbled but happens one of
the great things about english is you
can build new words it's built to do
that like
just a faction i've been doing that a
lot here i've been embracing my look
isn't it
it's just who i am take it or leave it
we understand you
wow
logan says matt what are your thoughts
on the mises caucus
um i am a big fan so the mises caucus is
a wing of the libertarian party
um and i am a big fan of all of their
work against lockdowns and i'm i'm kind
of a one-issue person right now
and and i think they've they've done a
heroic job i i will say that some
libertarians have been a little skittish
about opposing lockdowns and vaccine
mandates and i don't get that i don't
get that from a libertarian perspective
it doesn't make any sense to me
john galion says tim cuomo did not have
the mercy it was the comfort luke
where's the shirt auntie faucist ian
graffin is just gentrified pencil oh my
oh
well
the major truth is more finally refined
i like that
very pointed comment
are you gonna make an anti-faucist
that sounds good i'm going to talk to my
team about it now
i'll work i'll work with you on this we
have a sticker um uh faucism
and it's it's fouchy with uh with the
puppets what's going to be the flag
though is it going to be like a black
and yellow flag what's the symbol inside
of the old anti-fat symbol
but instead of antifa it's
faucism it's it's just a mask
anti-fouchus action yes yeah there you
go yeah i like that auntie fouches with
our own antifa flag yes sean anderson
says matt if the next three years in
this country was a rush song which would
it be one closer to the heart two
bastille day three or three grand finale
from 20 from 21 12.
oh i have to give some context i'm going
to say closer to the heart because i'm
trying to be an optimist but at the end
of 2112 uh which is referenced uh the
good guy kills himself because the state
has destroyed his life
so we don't we don't want that to happen
i'll stick with closer to the heart
let's go closer to the heart to the
heart
all right brian s says to no bread tube
watch max blumenthal with caleb maupin
and on rockfin bread tube is against the
left they're just democratic
establishment and get max blumenthal on
as a good example of the real left yes
that'd be great that'd be that would be
fantastic yeah i've seen him go by yeah
and we've referenced him before i
certainly think we disagree a lot of
things but i think he is absolutely
anti-establishment he does seem not
crazy yeah which i appreciate
i know that we we have been smeared
together in the past by these smeared
together that's a great
southern poverty law center wrote a
smear against me him and some other
people and for me it was like they
passively just smeared me he was the
focus of the article but they'd like
include my name or whatever that issue
an apology it's like a badge of honor
when the splc attacks you they got me a
couple years ago too yeah
all right seriously says stop ragging on
luke for his mispronunciations we all
know he sucks at speaking but that's why
we love him
hey i could take it don't tell tim what
to do it's fine all right
uh also what are the chances you could
widen the font on your website just a
tad often looks blurry why i don't know
maybe i
you know it's a design issue we'll talk
to the designers but you know i don't
know
all right
jfar says i know they probably hate each
other and it may sound crazy but the
smart move is a trump desantis in 24 for
trump's final term then desantis and
someone else in 28 and 32
for a maga america first three-peat idk
just a thought love you guys let's go
brandon
i actually agree with that um
yeah that would be the rational thing to
do we talked about this a few weeks ago
but we said because of the ego there
especially with trump firing the first
shots against desantis i do not believe
that will happen because desantis i
believe would would get too much
attention and donald trump would be
jealous of that but donald trump also
wants someone who's completely different
than him that's why he brought in
someone like a pence who's a a big
statist
to counter to kind of counterbalance him
uh but i think the two are going to be
fighting it's going to get crazy and
it's going to it's going to get wild
between these two
jordan says have you reached out to
jimmy dore would love to see him on the
show
uh travel might be the difficult thing i
think where's jimmy's california i think
so but jimmy's fantastic he's he's great
i love jimmy dore yeah uh so we would
love to have him on the show he'd be
awesome you know i will i will say this
too like the challenge of trying to get
people who have their own shows on our
show is that we're asking them not to do
their show to do our show so it's it's
difficult
you know so when people are like why
won't tim come on my show i'm like i do
my own show and i don't expect you to
abandon your show for my show either so
i'm not going to cry about some of these
you know prominent leftists not wanting
to come on if they're doing a show but
many of these leftists aren't show hosts
they're leftist you know columnist or
anything like that
all right let's see we'll grab some more
super chats
save me from canada says well we'll try
to try yes sure our drive for war might
decrease but who would want china to
dominate the world that is a war that
would be necessary to keep freedom they
are an expansionist authoritarian empire
that's that's that's that's a difficult
thing man
what do you do i mean the the the left
in this country is overwhelmingly
authoritarian but so is the communist
party and if we fight it just they're
gonna end up winning stop feeding the
beast stop stop you know start
prioritizing and voting with your dollar
i mean what a lot of these multinational
corporations do is essentially giving
china exactly what they need to grow
their empire and it wouldn't be possible
if it wasn't for our consumerism so
that's another aspect that is definitely
worth considering here in my opinion but
god how do you how do you get people to
stop consuming
well uh you know bringing back jobs and
factories to the united states could be
a start incentivizing you know
programs that don't just focus on slave
labor would be another one consume
locally yeah
all right little tails farm says hey tim
here's another super chat youtube quit
blocking my name it's little tails farm
uh it's it's u.s little tails farm with
the first goat super chat you're getting
our first born it would be an honor bro
i think we would all love the goat i'm
so down somebody two you can't have one
you need at least two then we need two
give us your second born as well
the best of your goals
little tails farm i think yeah uh y'all
were the ones who posted that funny
video of the chicken house yeah and then
like the camera goes up it's a house and
it goes with the window and there's a
chicken just
in the window like looking out and it
was just really funny chickens are
really funny so in my office it's all
windows all the way around it's like a
sunroom and i can see the chicken city
and it's really funny because like i was
working the other day and then like i'm
like reading some article one of a
sudden i hear like a bagak and i look
over and one of the chickens apparently
had grabbed a cricket or something and
it was being chased in circles by all
the other chickens they're playing
cricket because because they want to
steal the chicken the cricket from its
mouth and it's just watching them all
run in circles for like a minute and i'm
just like
and these things are crazy
they're communists this is why you need
goats
i'm looking forward to the goats
screaming though right yeah no only the
male goats right bleating i believe is
the phrase no they scream
that video goats
do you put them in there in the city
with the chickens or they hang out in
the yard no i think the goats will have
their own separate area okay yeah goat
town goat
goat that was a movie right silence of
the goats
gotta shut them up
all right free men die free says it's
time to get the great ron paul uh it's
time the great ron paul is brought on
the show it would break the internet and
with the mainstream media in shambles
it's the right time to hit them hard it
would be an honor and a privilege to
have a star and angel on the show in one
man can you make it happen luke i
reached out but it's it's also two hours
it's also very late so we would probably
have to change our shooting program in
order to maybe we could maybe um
where's he he's interested he's in uh
he's around houston texas closer to
galveston maybe we need to go out there
for another adventure i agree yeah and
then we could do it and we could shoot
it a little bit earlier and well we
could we could do a segment and then we
could do the show and then and be like
here's the you know the interview we did
with uh we could probably shoot it in
his house he has a beautiful house and
then he has the liberty tree there we
could like start the show with it and
then it would be maybe like a half an
hour or however long he was able to go
because he's older guy yeah yeah and
then it would just jump to the regular
show and we'd finish off live
we
went to him
and as last time i talked to him uh ron
won't get on a plane as long as he has
to wear a mask i don't blame him he's
like fu
i'm ron paul
do we need to just uh uh
get him a private plane
oh
we might probably fly him out here and
in style private planes have gotten
really really expensive that probably
works yeah yeah you think so yeah
i don't know maybe we'll we'll ask why i
don't want to do it i'll ask them i
really love the idea of having random
ronda all to get on together
because i've never seen him hanging out
together talking about politics that'd
be really fun to not that we do one in
the other but i would love to see him
yeah rand just did ron's show oh in i
think i assume he was in texas so i i
think that would be a cool thing oh
right yeah
it's really crazy to me that uh how
they're able to vilify rand paul
when he just
you know he made the brianna taylor no
knock warrant bill and the left attacked
him
what is wrong with these people like
rand paul people should just be like
i can imagine people being like well i
don't completely agree with him but he's
a good dude
but they just hate him and he was right
all along especially with when it came
to all the information surrounding dr
fauci
yeah he was accurate
and then that is just that is just epic
yeah his confrontations with fouchy well
researched holding up the documents
i guess that's what it's all about if
you're an authoritarian you don't like
someone challenging the authority so
they don't like them
my friends if you haven't already smash
that like button do it for ian yes do it
and subscribe to this channel go to
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only podcast going up around 11 p.m
tonight we do that monday through
thursday there's a huge library of
connor you can go back in time and see
all of our great conversations with
steve bannon alex jones we've had
michael knowles we got marjorie taylor
green recently just a whole bunch of
really awesome people we'll have one of
those up tonight it's going to be a lot
of fun it's uncensored a lot of cursing
don't have your kids be around when you
watch it but uh your your supporters
members helps make all this possible you
can follow the show at tim cast irl
basically everywhere or it might be tim
cast underscore irl or something
and you can follow me at timcast on
twitter and instagram check out my
if you want to see nonsensical in a
sarcastic facetious tweets and trolling
follow me on twitter it's a lot of fun
matt you want to shout anything out uh
if you want to check out we we primarily
make documentaries if you want to check
them out go to freethepeople.org
we did a beautiful anti-lockdown video
called all we have
it's emotionally devastating but it's
it's something that
we wanted to connect with people outside
of our community
and uh just check it out
right on cool maybe we could even work
on something in the future let's
definitely talk about that today i
played a really funny video of dr fauci
exposing himself in my uh youtube report
on youtube.com forward slash we are
change it's definitely worth a watch and
i did another video about the fight in
florida on luke uncensored.com hope to
see some of you guys there thanks for
having me and uh this was a great
conversation even though it got pretty
testy in the comment section especially
with uh some of the trump criticism
there but
uh you know hey you know i i appreciate
the the criticism and if you have any uh
evidence or or counterpoints i'm always
open to hearing your point of views and
that's and i'll say this too like
this is an eclectic show man yeah yeah
and thanks for pointing out when i that
my tds got a little uh fiery i made an
assumption about maybe something trump
thought or felt i don't have any
justification for that and that anger
was unjust unjustifiable so i apologize
for letting that out although
i'm glad i went through it hey and i
want to shout out your twitter mkibby on
twitter mkb on twitter where can people
get the shirt uh
i'm told that it's not available at this
very moment but at freethepeople.org we
have a shop and we have all sorts of
cool things and you can get our fouchism
gear as well and uh
it's it's very cool stuff we have a we
have an artist on staff who's a very
accomplished comic book artist and he
does all of our stuff it's really cute
and it's really cool well follow me in
crossland.net i'll catch you guys later
i did check out the shop for free the
people so let's switch the camera
properly i did check out the shop for
the people that version of the shirt is
not available with yellow which i love
but there is one that's like gray and
has black print on it it's black and has
gray prints if you guys want that shirt
just not necessarily with the yellow
which i know is a libertarian color um
you can still get it on the site for the
people uh anarchist color yeah
steelers steelers buddy exactly yeah
it's a lot of different different colors
yeah it's good um freethepeople.org
shop shop excellent shop very cute
anyway you guys may follow me on twitter
at sourpatchlids we will see all of you
at timcast.com around 11 or so p.m
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you